lors du jour appelle l'examen des
crédits de la mission travaillait emploi
les articles 47 48 et 49 du projet de
finances
paroles est à Monsieur Daniel Breuillet
en premier rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame et monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues avec plus de 20 milliards
d'euros la mission travaille emplois est
après la mission écologique celle dans
la progression et la plus forte par
rapport à la loi de finance initiale
cependant compte tenu du volume très
important de crédit supplémentaire
provenant en 21 et 22 de collectif
budgétaires du plan de relance et de
fonds de concours nous serons en réalité
dans des ordres de grandeur comparable à
ce constater ces deux dernières années
ces mouvements en cours d'exercice et
les écarts considérables entre crédit
votés et exécutés ont notablement
brouillé la lisibilité du budget de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle depuis deux ans nous
espérons nous prononcer aujourd'hui sur
des bases plus conformes à ce que sera
réellement l'impact de ce budget en 2023
j'évoquerai plus particules plus
particulièrement le volet de la mission
relative à la politique de l'emploi tout
d'abord je voudrais dire que les moyens
très importants consacrés depuis 2020 la
politique portée par cette mission ont
certainement joué un rôle dans
l'amélioration de la situation de
l'emploi je pense notamment à
l'apprentissage la hausse du nombre de
contrats d'apprentissage représente près
de la moitié de la baisse du nombre de
chômeurs la dépense budgétaire s'est
alourdie d'autres dépenses sont diminués
et l'assurance chômage n'est plus en
déficit concernant la mission le recul
du chômage entraîne une nette diminution
des dépenses d'allocations prises en
charge par l'État de l'ordre de 500
millions un versement la progression de
l'emploi major de près de 700 millions
la compensation à la sécurité sociale
des exonérations de cotisations il
s'agit d'une dépense qui atteint 5
milliards d'euros soit un quart du
budget total de la mission
s'agissant des actions en faveur de
publics spécifiques le budget destiné
aux entreprises adaptées poursuit sa
progression le contrôle effectué par
Emmanuel Capu pour la commission des
finances montre plusieurs freins
subsistants développement de ce type
d'emploi
d'expérimentation de nouvelles formes
d'insertion dans l'emploi des personnes
handicapées n'a pas encore donné les
résultats escomptés
les dotations pour l'insertion par
l'activité économique sont maintenus au
niveau de 2022 ce qui diminuera le
nombre d'emplois finançables elles ont
certes notablement augmenté depuis trois
ans mais cette simple stabilisation pose
question et rémunération des
bénéficiaires de l'IAE indexées sur le
SMIC vont augmenter à crédit égaux il
pourrait donc avoir moins de
bénéficiaires des acteurs de l'IAE
manque de visibilité sur la répartition
territoriale de l'enveloppe entre les
différents types de structures alors que
le coût des contrats sera plus élevé les
actions en faveur de l'accompagnement
renforcer des jeunes vers l’emploi
prennent quant à elle une part accrue
dans le budget de la mission avec le
contrat d'engagement jeunes CEJ mis en
place le 1er mars dernier et dont la
dotation atteint un milliard d'euros ce
dispositif a été introduit dans des
conditions critiques câbles sans
évaluation préalable en cours de
discussion budgétaire du PLF 2022
calcul manque pour en effectuer une
évaluation approfondie toutefois les
premiers éléments recueillis sont plutôt
encourageants ça montait en charge
objective 300.000 jeunes cette année
concernera essentiellement les missions
locales sur lesquelles reposent en
majorité cet accompagnement intensif des
jeunes présentant comme on dit
pudiquement des besoins périphériques
importants l'État le rapporte un soutien
sensiblement supérieur je parle des
missions locales à celui dont elle
bénéficiait il y a encore trois ou
quatre ans les conditions d'orientation
des jeunes soit vers Pôle emploi soit
vers les missions locales ont été
clarifiées il semble que le CEJ et même
permis d'améliorer les échanges entre
deux opérateurs agissant jusqu'à présent
de manière trop cloisonnée la gestion du
dispositif pourrait induire une charge
administrative assez lourde au détriment
des charges d'accompagnement notamment
pour satisfaire aux conditions
d'activité minimales il y a sans doute
matière à simplifier dans ce domaine de
même il faudrait être vigilant pour que
le CEJ s'articule au mieux avec les
structures comme les écoles de la
deuxième chance ou des pides en résumé
le CEJ me paraît améliorer le dispositif
de la garantie jeune et mérite d'être
consolidée j'ai mentionné Pôle emploi la
subvention de l'État avait baissé
jusqu'en 2021
elle a été stabilisée en 2022 et
augmente de 136 millions 2023 dans le
même temps les crédits attribués au
titre de la mission plan de relance ne
sont pas reconduits le plafond d'emplois
de Pôle emploi en très légère baisse
sera globalement maintenu en 2023 au
niveau de ces deux dernières années ces
moyens ont été renforcés pour le CEJ
l'accompagnement des chômeurs de très
longue durée et le plan de réduction des
tensions de recrutement toutefois les
évolutions de Pôle Emploi au-delà 2023
sont suspendus aux résultats des travaux
lancés sur France travail le
gouvernement monsieur le ministre s'est
défendu de vouloir fusionner ou refondre
l'organisation des acteurs du service
public de l'emploi pour autant à ce jour
vous n'avez pas indiqué en quoi
consistera cette réforme on nous a
plutôt dit en quoi elle ne consisterait
pas à mon sens l'enjeu porte sur une
réelle coordination des acteurs de
terrain pour mieux identifier les
personnes
nécessitant un accompagnement mieux
orienté mieux partager des données mieux
assurées le suivi je ne sais à ce stade
si France travaille répondra réellement
à ce besoin je relève que les prévisions
indicatives pour les dépenses de
fonctionnement du programme Accès retour
à l'emploi constitué à près de 90% de la
subvention à Pôle Emploi marque une
diminution de 11% 2024 et de 12% en 2025
le recul du chômage ne doit pas masquer
la persistance d'un nombre encore bien
trop important de personnes très
éloignées de l'emploi notamment parmi
les jeunes c'est pour ces publics que
les besoins d'accompagnement sont les
plus élevés l'effort en leur direction
doit être maintenue et même renforcée
pour les mêmes raisons je suis attaché à
ce qu'en matière d'apprentissage et de
formation professionnelle une attention
prioritaire soit portée à ceux qui ont
le moins de facilité à s'insérer sur le
marché du travail ou à accéder aux
formations voilà les observation que je
souhaitais formuler sur cette mission en
mon nom et en celui de mon corps
rapporteur Emmanuel Capu mission dans
les crédits sont confortés dans ce
projet de budget la commission des
finances suivant sagement nos
recommandations vous en propose
l'adoption
merci cher collègue et maintenant la
parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Capu
rapport sur spécial également de la
commission des finances
également pour cette minute
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je vais donc pour ma part
aborder le second volet de la mission à
savoir le financement de l'apprentissage
et de la formation professionnelle
le succès de l'apprentissage au-delà de
toute prévision et paradoxalement la
source d'une des difficultés budgétaires
majeures de cette mission avec un poids
financier qui dépasse largement celui de
toutes les autres missions pardon de
toutes les autres actions de la mission
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude exprimé à de
multiples reprises en commission comme
en séance publique particulièrement à
l'occasion des rallonges budgétaires
successives accordées à France
compétences
ces inquiétudes sont légitimes mais
l'apprentissage comme la formation
professionnelle constitue aussi un enjeu
essentiel si nous voulons progresser
vers le plein emploi un objectif vers
lequel beaucoup de chemin restent à
parcourir même si la situation s'est
améliorée puisque par rapport à fin 2019
l'emploi salarié a progressé de 800 000
personnes et le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi diminué de près de 400 000
personnes
présenter de longues dates comme la
meilleure voie d'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes
l'apprentissage a longtemps stagné
le nombre annuel de contrats conclus a
même baissé de 2012 à 2017 avant de
remonter nettement en 2018 et 2019 puis
de décoller un rythme tout à fait
inattendu près de 740 000 contrats
conclus en 2021 deux fois plus qu'en
2019 et autant si non plus en 2022
sous l'angle budgétaire la question de
l'apprentissage se pose à deux niveaux
assez différents le premier est celui du
soutien de l'État à travers les aides à
l'embauche
l'aide exceptionnelle mise en place en
2020 qui concerne toutes les entreprises
y compris les entreprises de plus de 250
salariés et les formations allant
jusqu'au bac + 5 à certainement jouer
dans l'essor de l'apprentissage mais le
coût budgétaire a bondit de 1,3
milliards en 2020 à 4,2 milliards en
2021 pour 2022 le montant sera
certainement du même ordre la question
d'un nouveau paramétrage de cette aide
est aujourd'hui posée elle fait l'objet
de discussion entre le gouvernement et
les partenaires sociaux ce qui me paraît
tout à fait appropriées il est
certainement nécessaire de faire la part
entre de probables effets d'aubaine et
des incitations utiles au maintien de la
dynamique actuelle de l'apprentissage
il semblait exclu de revenir purement et
simplement à l'aide unique d'avant 2020
mais nous ignorons pour l'heure si l'on
s'oriente vers une diminution du montant
de l'aide actuel ou un ciblage sur
certaines entreprises ou certains
niveaux de formation peut-être monsieur
le ministre serez-vous en mesure de
donner quelques indications sur les
options privilégiées
et Madame la Ministre également
en tout état de cause tous les contrats
conclus avant la fin de l'année 2022
bénéficieront pour un an de l'actuel
régime des aides à l’embauche l'effet
budgétaire d'une révision à la baisse ne
se fera donc sentir qu'à l'échéance des
contrats actuels et à la conclusion de
nouveaux contrats c'est-à-dire en large
partie sur les quatre derniers mois de
2023 c'est la raison pour laquelle un
amendement de réduction de crédit me
paraît pas nécessairement efficace mais
c'est surtout la situation financière de
France compétences qui pose le problème
budgétaire le plus difficile l'État a dû
intervenir à hauteur de près de 3
milliards en 2021 puis à nouveau de 4
milliards en 2022 ce qui n'évitera pas
un déficit estimé autour de 3 milliards
et demi en fin d'année
je rappelle qu'à sa création aucun
soutien de l'État cette opérateur n'a
été envisagé à l'inverse la loi de 2018
prévoit même le versement à l'état par
France compétences d'une contribution à
la formation des demandeurs d'emploi
contribution de 1,6 milliards d'euros
par an depuis 2019 les quarts c'est
rapidement creusé entre les ressources
de France compétent qui évoluent en
fonction de la masse salariale et ses
dépenses à savoir le financement de
l'alternance et celui du CPF
ces deux dispositifs constituant des
enveloppes ouvertes
s'agissant plus particulièrement du CPF
qui représente environ un cinquième des
dépenses un certain nombre de mesures de
luttes contre la fraude de sécurisation
de des référencements d'organismes ont
été prises
des dispositions législatives figurent
dans la proposition de loi adopter à
l'Assemblée nationale qui sera discuté
ici même le 8 décembre prochain le très
large éventail de formation finançable
rend nécessaire incontestablement une
régulation dont le principe a été
introduit dans l'article 49 rattaché à
la mission je soutiens ce principe et je
proposerai de le préciser par un
amendement que nous examinerons tout à
l'heure
par ailleurs à travers le projet de loi
de finances l'état des charges France
compétences d'une bonne part de la
contribution qu'elle lui verse au titre
de la formation des demandeurs d'emploi
comme la souligner la Cour des comptes
le niveau de cette contribution par
essai excessif d'autant plus que les
dotations du pic qu'elle vient abonder
ne sont que partiellement consommés et
font l'objet de reports importants
deuxièmement une subvention à France
compétence d'un montant de 1,7 milliards
est inscrite d'emblée dans les crédits
de la mission ce point de vue le PLF
2023 n'apparaît plus sincère que celui
2022 qui passait totalement sous silence
ce déficit l'ensemble de ces mesures
atténue la contrainte financière sur
France compétences sans pour autant
assurer nous le savons bien son
équilibre financier une révision des
niveaux de prise en charge des contrats
d'apprentissage est intervenu en
septembre dernier avec un effet
d'économie évalué à 200 millions en 2023
une autre révision ou intervenir en
avril 2023
au-delà il faudra sans doute définir des
priorités en termes de niveau de soutien
selon les différents types de structures
et de niveau de formation
l'image de l'apprentissage c'est
profondément transformée c'est un acquis
majeur de la réforme qu'il faut
préserver mais il est maintenant
indispensable que l'État en lien avec
les partenaires sociaux
et définissent une trajectoire
soutenable pour les financements de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage sans casser la dynamique
en cours
c'est la raison pour laquelle mes chers
collègues sous le bénéfice de ces
observations la commission des finances
vous propose comme l'a dit mon collègue
co-rapporteur Daniel Breuillet
l'adoption des crédits de la mission
travail et emploi pour 2023
merci chers collègues et maintenant
la parole est à Madame puissard
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires sociales
pour 2023 la mission travaille emploie
se caractérise par une progression
considérable de ces crédits +
42%. et par de nombreuses incertitudes
nous devons nous prononcer alors que de
nombreux changements sont attendus en
2023 lancement de France travail
redéfinition des aides à l'apprentissage
fait attendu du pic financement toujours
certain de France compétences dans ce
contexte la commission des affaires
sociales propose de diminuer les crédits
de cette mission sur deux postes de
dépenses la subvention à France
compétences et le pic si on veut
continuer de développer l'apprentissage
et la formation professionnelle il est
urgent de sécuriser leur financement or
à ce stade aucune réponse pérenne est
apportée au déséquilibre financier de
France compétences l'établissement
accumule les déficits alors même qu'il
va recevoir 4 milliards d'euros de
subventions en 2022 est une enveloppe de
1,6 milliards d'euros est prévu pour
2000 23
il est urgent de régler cette situation
aujourd'hui insoutenable de première
mesure de régulation des dépenses sont
engagées il faut aller plus loin
proposant à cet effet d'instituer un
plafonnement de la prise en charge par
le CSP du coût de certaines formations
amendement qui a été évoqué par mon
collègue dans cette logique la
commission vous pose également de
diminuer de 300 millions d'euros la
subvention à France compétence cette
réduction doit être la contrepartie
d'une plus forte régulation des dépenses
d'apprentissage et du CPF et d'une
réduction plus significative de la
contribution de France compétence opique
concernant le pic qui a été prolongé
jusqu'en 2023 nous pensons que l'année
prochaine devra être marquée par une
revue des dispositifs financés par ce
plan afin d'évoluer l'opportunité de
maintenir leur financement à ce stade
les annonces du gouvernement n'ont pas
apporté de précisions sur l'avenir de
ces dispositifs ni même sur la fin
effective du pic sans affecter le
développement de la formation dans les
régions ne semble qu'une telle
évaluation doit être rapidement engagée
et que les moyens du pic doivent
correspondre à ceux d'une dernière année
d'exécution considérant que ce plan doit
prendre sa prochainement trouve que ça
contribution directe à la formation et à
l'insertion n'est pas mesurée et que son
pilotage est toujours pas satisfaisant
nous proposons de diminuer les moyens du
pic à hauteur de 500 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement s'il faut se
réjouir de la diminution des dépenses
allocations de solidarité pour les
demandeurs d'emploi signe une
conjoncture favorable nous ne savons pas
de corrélation dans les moyens loués à
Pôle emploi qui eux progressent de 17%.
il faudra sans tarder évaluer la
pertinence du maintien des effectifs de
Pôle Emploi qui avait été accordée à
titre exceptionnel lors de la crise
sanitaire en matière d'insertion dans
l'emploi la réduction des objectifs
d'entrée en contrat aidé et en emploi
front paraît adapté à l'amélioration de
la situation de l'emploi la trajectoire
de monter en charge du contrat
d'engagement jeune est également
cohérente il faudra mesurer les effets
de ces dispositifs sur l'insertion dans
l'emploi durable en particulier dans le
cas de la mise en place de France
travail sous réserve de ces observations
la Commission a mis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de la mission et
aux articles qui sont rattachés voici
Monsieur le Président trois minutes
d'intervention qui peuvent rapporter
gros pour le budget de l'État je vous
remercie
il me reste même 10 secondes
par la suite notre discussion je
rappelle que le temps de parole
autorisez à chaque groupe pour chaque
unité discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote il n'y a pas de
duplication par ailleurs le gouvernement
dispose au total monsieur le ministre
madame la ministre de 15 minutes pour
intervenir nous commençons donc la
discussion générale proprement dite la
parole est à perdre l'harmonie pour 9
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
budget la mission travaillait emploi
pour 2023 s'élève à 20 milliards 900
millions d'euros si la progression de ce
budget par rapport à 2022 semble
importante il fut combien de la
relativiser en effet ces chiffres sont
le résultat d'une plus grande
compensation des exonérations de
cotisation sociale compensation qui
représente à présent un quart des crédit
de la mission mais aussi cette hausse
affichée des crédits résulte de
changement de périmètre certains
dispositifs étant financé l'an prochain
par le budget du ministère du travail
après avoir été pris en charge jusque
fin 2022 par des crédits du plan de
relance au final a bien aimé regarder
l'exercice 2023 débutera avec un niveau
de crédit proche de l'an dernier et
l'avenir n'est pas rieur puisque le
gouvernement a déjà acté une baisse
importante du budget de la mission pour
2024 et 2025
il s'agit pas évidemment de nier que le
taux de chômage s'élève à 7,4% à la fin
du second trimestre mais nous voulons
rappeler que le FCE prévoit une remontée
du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi en 2023
et 2024 et surtout gardons à l'esprit
que nos concitoyens les plus éloignés du
marché du travail sont ceux pour
lesquelles les freins préalables au
retour à l'emploi sont nombreux il est
donc indispensable que les politiques
publiques soient adaptées pour mieux
prendre en charge ceux pour qui les
obstacles semblent parfois insurmontable
il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur notre
marché du travail tout d'abord parce que
la semaine dernière nous avons eu la
confirmation dans le rapport annuel le
Proxinvest que les rémunérations des
dirigeants des 120 plus grandes sociétés
cotées ont augmenté en moyenne de 22%
par rapport à 2019 portant la
rémunération moyenne à 4,5 millions
d'euros c'est un record historique
depuis 15 ans
et le même jour quasiment vous monsieur
le ministre du Travail vous présentiez
les nouvelles règles d'assurance chômage
à niveau en défaveur des plus fragiles
et des seniors il faut rappeler que
seuls 55% des 55 64 ans travaillent dans
notre pays et que ce taux d'emploi reste
de 6 points inférieurs à la moyenne des
pays européens malgré ces constats
largement partagés le gouvernement a
choisi de réduire de 25% la durée
d'indemnisation pour tous les salariés
en fin d'indemnisation et nouvellement
inscrits à Pôle emploi à compter du 1er
février prochain ce sont ainsi près de 3
à 4 milliards d'euros d'économie qui
seront réalisés au détriment des
salariés et des chômeurs et nous
considérons que ce n'est pas acceptable
l'idée selon laquelle une baisse des
droits des demandeurs d'emploi améliorer
leur entrée sur le marché du travail est
un leurre les difficultés de recrutement
actuel viennent d'abord d'un déficit de
compétences qui au besoin des
entreprises et également des conditions
de travail proposées nous pas l'ignorer
nous ne souscrivons pas à l'idée selon
laquelle il faudrait donner toujours
moins à locataire indemnisés par
l'assurance chômage et affaiblir encore
davantage le service public de l'emploi
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est
toujours plus difficile d'obtenir un
rendez-vous avec un conseiller Pôle
Emploi les délais sont d'autant plus
importants d'ailleurs que les horaires
d'accueil sont réduits on demande aux
allocataires de se débrouiller seul face
à leur ordinateur en somme de faire leur
démarche en ligne ce qui occasionne de
réelles difficultés pour nombre d'entre
eux car rien ne remplace un accueil
physique par un professionnel formé et à
l'écoute le résultat d'ailleurs c'est
qu'il n'y a jamais eu autant de
contestations pour cause d'erreur dans
le calcul des indemnités notamment il
n'y a jamais eu autant de conseillers
agressés verbalement ou pire tant les
tensions sont importantes et nous
doutons que les choses aillent mieux
avec la nouvelle réforme qui va apporter
encore de la complexité et accroître les
incompréhensions j'entends le
gouvernement nous expliquer qu'il
faudrait faire des économies
mais je réponds qu'avec un budget pardon
ce sont des dépenses mais aussi des
recettes et que les choix opérés
aujourd'hui sont avant tout et
évidemment des choix politiques depuis
l'ouverture des débats sur le PLF et
auparavant sont le PLFSS notre groupe a
formulé de nombreuses propositions en
matière de recettes que le gouvernement
rejette toutes au final qui va être
impacté toujours les mêmes les plus
fragiles ce qui subissent les contrats
précaires et les périodes d'inactivité
je l'ai déjà mentionné un quart de
crédit de la mission se résume à des
compensations d'exonération de
cotisations sociales nous pensons que
leur impact mériterait d'être mieux
évalué d'autant plus que ces politiques
s'inscrivent dans la durée car tout cela
finalement ça coûte cher ça coûte cher
soit la sécurité sociale soit au budget
de l'État et au total c'est un
désarmement fiscal qui n'est pas sans
conséquence
s'agissant de l'insertion par la
l'activité économique qui apporte une
contribution réelle à l'insertion des
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
nous ferons des propositions si ce
secteur a bénéficié d'un soutien ces
dernières années employant aujourd'hui
près de 150 000 salariés nous ne pouvons
passer l'inquiétude des partis prenantes
en raison de la hausse du SMIC sur
lesquels les rémunérations des
bénéficiaires de l'IAE sont indexées on
peut craindre qu'enveloppe constante le
nombre de postes finançable soit moindre
ce qui remettrait en cause l'élan
constatées le secteur regroupe par
ailleurs des structures de statuts
différents des entreprises
intermédiaires des associations
intermédiaires des ateliers des
chantiers d'insertion avec de forts
écarts d'aide au poste les acteurs de
l'IAE soulignent un certain manque de
visibilité pour 2023 dû aux incertitudes
sur la réparatisation territoriale de
l'enveloppe entre les différents types
de structures alors que le coût des
contrats lui sera plus élevé qu'en 2022
concernant France compétences je
rappelle que la commission des affaires
sociales a adopté au mois de juin
dernier un rapport très complet intitulé
France compétences face à une crise de
croissance donc Corinne Ferret était
Cora porteur avec Martin lévrier et
Frédéric puissant
ce rapport avait formulé 40 propositions
pour une meilleure régulation tendue CPF
que de l'apprentissage là encore
personne ne peut ignorer que dès 2020
France compétences s'est trouvée dans
une situation financière très
déséquilibrée
occasionnant un important déficit ce
déficit a des causes structurels dont
les conséquences auraient pu être mieux
anticipées en pratique les deux
principaux dispositifs financés par
France compétences l'apprentissage et le
CPF constituent des enveloppes ouvertes
ainsi le nombre de places en CFA n'est
plus contingenté chaque contrat
d'apprentissage voudra à une prise en
charge sur les fonds de France
compétences quant au droit de la
formation à la formation professionnelle
désormais monétisée ils peuvent être
directement mobilisés par les titulaires
du CPF avec tous les mixer dont nous
discuterons d'ailleurs prochainement
dans le cadre de l'examen d'une
proposition de loi pour faire face des
subventions ont-ils du soutien à la
trésorerie de France compétence sont
inscrites au bruit sont inscrites au
budget 2023 nous avions déjà cet été
lors du vote de la loi de finance
rectificative pour 2022 acté un soutien
à cet instant encore renforcé ce mois-ci
par une nouvelle subvention de l'État
hauteur de 2 milliards plus globalement
on voit bien que rien ne pourra se faire
sans une plus grande responsabilisation
mobilisation des acteurs de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
qui passe par un dialogue renforcé avec
les branches professionnelles avec les
partenaires sociaux il n'appartient pas
au Parlement ni au pouvoir réglementaire
de se substituer à ces derniers et de
faire passer les réformes certaines
nécessaires mais là en force
je terminerai en soulignant que l'examen
de cette mission intervient dans un
contexte de préfiguration encore très
flou de la réforme du service public du
travail avec la création de France
travail censé faire le pendant à France
compétences contenu de ce qu'il s'est
passé avec cet instant de gouvernance
nationale nous émettons des craintes et
nous réaffirmons notre souhait d'une
meilleure coordination des acteurs de
l'emploi sur le terrain pour mieux
cibler mieux identifier les personnes
nécessitant un accompagnement les
orientés mieux partager les données et
assurer un meilleur suivi vous vous en
doutez dans la mesure où ce budget acte
d'une réduction des dépenses du
programme 102 dans la mesure où le
compte n'y est pas davantage concernant
la jeunesse
notre groupe plus que jamais opposé à
toutes les coupes budgétaires à ces
dispositifs et contrats que vous nous
vantez fonder je cite sur des droits et
de voir alors qu'il procède d'une
volonté unique de l'État nous
n'approuvrons pas les crédits de cette
mission je vous remercie merci chers
collègues et la parole maintenant
et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le projet de loi de finances pour 2023
prévoit une augmentation des crédits de
la mission travail emploi de 4,5
milliards d'euros cette augmentation
masque en réalité une modification
périmètre de la mission avec
l'intégration des crédits de l'activité
partielle qui figurait auparavant dans
la mission plan de relance cette
augmentation masque également la baisse
des crédits destinés au programme Accès
et retour à l'emploi et notamment de
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
de 500 millions d'euros le gouvernement
justifie cette diminution des crédits
par l'amélioration de la situation de
l'emploi et des conséquences de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage avec
cette réforme si le taux de chômage
passe sous la barre de 9% après une
période de six mois la durée de
l'indemnisation sera réduite de 25%
concrètement à partir du 1er février
2023 un salarié de moins de 53 ans ne
sera indemnisé que pendant 18 mois au
lieu de 24 aujourd'hui un salarié de
plus de 55 ans sera indemnisé pendant 27
mois au lieu de 36 aujourd'hui cette
réforme va baisser les droits des
chômeurs et selon le secrétaire national
de la CFDT n'aura pas d'effet sur
l'emploi sauf à brosser dans le sens du
poil un électorat et à faire des
économies budgétaires le gouvernement
veut en réalité faire 4 milliards
d'euros d'économies sur le système
d'assurance chômage les personnes sans
emploi seront contraintes d'accepter des
métiers pénible mal payés en réduisant
les indemnissions les indemnisations
chômage à l'opposé du projet de du
gouvernement nous considérons qu'il faut
revaloriser le travail lui redonner tout
son sens afin que chacun y retrouve le
goût avec de bons salaires et de bonnes
conditions de travail vous refusez
d'augmenter les salaires et de
revaloriser les métiers essentiels c'est
vous qui portez la responsabilité de la
dévalorisation du sens du travail qui
n'est plus un lieu d'épanouissement mais
de mal-être et de souffrance ce projet
de loi de finance pour 2023 prévoit
également la réforme du service public
de l'emploi avec le projet France
travail dont les contours demeurent
encore très flous si un préfet
figurateur a été nommé pour préparer sa
mise en place dès 2024 les acteurs ne
disposent d'aucun élément précis sur son
périmètre et son contenu les enjeux sont
multiples ainsi cuite des jeunes les
plus éloignés du travail qui doivent
être immobilisés et affrontent des
problématiques dites périphériques aucun
financement n'est aujourd'hui fléchés
vers des solutions et les missions
locales ont trop peu de leviers enfin
s'agissant de l'inspection du travail
nous alertons sur la situation du
personnel et notamment désaspectrice et
désinspecteurs qui rencontrent une crise
de perte de doublé d'un manque de
reconnaissance de leur direction face à
un capitalisme de plus en plus agressif
nous avons besoin d'une inspection du
travail fort pour faire respecter le
travail ainsi que celles et ceux qui
travaillent les crédits de
fonctionnement pour les services
déconcentrés de l'État et donc de
l'inspection du travail n'augmente que
de 2% en 2023 si les forts ne
s'accentuent pas il y a peu de chances
que ces difficultés se résorbent le
gouvernement réfléchit-il à de nouvelles
évolutions de l'organisation de
l'inspection du travail selon le rapport
de notre collègue député Pierre
d'arriville entre fin 2017 et mars 2022
le nombre des agents chargés du contrôle
des entreprises à diminué de 250
équivalents temps plein sur le terrain
cela se traduit par un fort nombre de
postes vacants au sein des sections de
contrôle le taux de vacances serait en
moyenne de 15%. cette situation empêche
l'affection du travail de remplir ses
missions un certain endroit du
territoire et créer des ruptures
d'égalité ce budget pour 2023 censé
permettre à la France d'atteindre le
plein emploi mais en réalité nous allons
passer du chômage de masse à la
précarité de masse pour l'ensemble de
ces raisons notre groupe votre a donc
contre les crédits de la mission travail
et emploi je vous remercie
merci chers
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente de commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues d'abord saluer le travail des
rapporteurs qui par leur propos nous ont
exposés les réalités de cette mission ce
qu'elle contient avec plus de 20
milliards d'euros consacrés dans ce PLF
2023 la mission travailler emplois est
avec la mission écologiste celle qui
enregistre la plus forte progression par
rapport à la loi de finances de 2022
l'analyse de la mission travaille en
poids se fait cette année dans un
contexte globalement rassurant on espère
que ça durera sur la question de
l'emploi en France le pays poursuit son
recul continu du chômage dont le taux
devrait s'établir selon les prévisions
de l'Institut national de la statistique
et des études économiques à
7,4% en fin d'année nous salu les
efforts déployés depuis plusieurs années
pour parvenir aux plein emploi objectif
primordial pour notre société la
tendance croissante des crédits de cette
mission travaille emploi et bienvenue
pour mener à bien les réformes qui
visent à développer les compétences
professionnelles des Français et à
réduire les inégalités d'accès à
l'emploi alors sur l'apprentissage comme
ça a été dit il faut saluer la
progression quantitative les chiffres
parlent de même ils ont été cités il
faut aussi saluer le regard qui a changé
et l'approche culturelle différente sur
l'apprentissage pour les jeunes leurs
familles et les entreprises certes nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau de
l'Allemagne j'aime à raconter le cas de
l'entreprise Bayer cette grande
entreprise chimique qui affiche dans son
siège comme premier chiffre première
fierté le nombre d'apprentis embauchés
chaque année et aux dépens même du
chiffre d'affaires ou du nombre de
salariés c'est une culture c'est le
modèle drainant donc pour résumer sur le
plan quantitatif toutes les objectifs en
nombre d'apprentissant atteint mais il y
a un mais l'approche qualitative des
contrats d'apprentissage signé nous
oblige à constater que bon nombre de
contrats concerne des bacs + 2 bac + 3
voire master ils sont même devenus pour
quelques étudiants pour beaucoup
d'étudiants même un moyen de financer
des études trop souvent coûteuses alors
est-ce le rôle de l'apprentissage de
financer les études pourquoi pas mais il
y a un certain nombre de conditions à
respecter d'abord la clarté des
objectifs et je pense pas que à l'époque
du débat sur avenir professionnel nous
ayons eu cette vision les objectifs ont
légèrement évolué que cela ne se fasse
pas dépend des de ce qu'on appelle
j'aime pas ce mot mais les décrocheurs
ou des métiers à faible qualification
que les métiers en tension et puis bien
évidemment qu'on respecte un équilibre
financier alors ça a été dit mes chers
collègues à ce sujet lorsqu'on parcourt
votre vos rapports on constate que
France compétences doit régulièrement
recourir à des emprunts qui certes une
dynamique mais à quel prix depuis 2020
ces dépenses de guichet dépassent
largement le produit des contributions
des des employeurs en 2021 le produit de
ses contributions s'élèvent à 8,8
milliards d'euros alors que les dépenses
en faveur de l'alternance représentent
9,3 milliards d'euros à ses dépenses
s'ajoutent celles liées au compte
personnel de formation estimé à 2,7
milliards d'euros pour 2021 alors sur ce
sujet je vois Martin lévrier il faudra
lutter contre l'Afrique du CPF bien
évidemment mais aussi réguler une
régulation et est nécessaire sera-t-elle
suffisante pour éviter un déficit
significatif en 2023 et puis bien
évidemment il y a la question de
l'équilibre financier d'avenir
professionnel
alors bref ce déficit de France
compétences pour 2023 pourrait être de
l'ordre de 4 milliards d'euros appelant
ainsi à de nouveaux emprunts et à des
soutiens complémentaires au budget de
l'État une telle situation n'est pas
acceptable pour le financement de
l'apprentissage et la formation
professionnelle et le retour à moyen
terme bien sûr mais le plus rapidement
possible à l'équilibre financier n'est
pas une option c'est une exigence le
programme 102 retour à l'emploi lui
baisse légèrement de l'ordre de 5% en
raison des prévisions de diminution du
nombre de bénéficiaires en fin de droit
à l'assurance chômage dans celui-ci nous
saluons l'augmentation des crédits du
secteur de l'IAE par l'intermédiaire du
fie les acronymes par sa dynamique et la
qualité de ces structures qui ont fait
leurs preuves ces dernières années la
politique de l'IAE est l'un des outils
les plus pertinents pour remettre des
hommes et des femmes en situation
durable de travail leur action est
indispensable si nous voulons
collectivement atteindre l'objectif de
7% de demandeurs d'emploi de longue
durée
pour se faire l'intelligence des
parcours et des accompagnements
sociaux professionnels doivent être
mobilisés afin d'aller chercher celles
et ceux qui souffrent de frein à
l'emploi et qui en sont les plus
éloignés le programme 102 voit aussi
également la traduction budgétaire du
CEG créé par la dernière loi de finance
l'accompagnement des quelques 300000
jeunes pour l'année 2023 dont 200 000
nouveaux bénéficiaires justifient les
quelques 800 millions d'euros prévus
pour l'émission locale
et et celle de Pôle Emploi un mot sur
les maisons de l'emploi ce dispositif
créé par Jean-Louis Paulo il doit
mériter toute notre attention c'est
pourquoi avec Françoise Ferrat notre
groupe a déposé un amendement pour
sécuriser les crédits et les augmenter
sur le dispositif territoire zéro
chômeurs il fait consensus le temps de
l'expérimentation sera bientôt passée le
résultat obtenu son positifs et
conséquents et la limite fixée des 50
communes au territoire et bientôt
atteinte et il est temps maintenant de
de réfléchir et de décider madame le
ministre monsieur le ministre ce que
nous allons faire par rapport au 134
nouveaux postulants
je ne reviens pas sur la question de la
futurance chômage je crois que le Sénat
a bien travaillé sur cette réforme que
nous avons eu un bon débat parlementaire
celui d'ailleurs la présence des des
deux ministres pour notre débat sur
cette mission j'ai l'impression que
entre vous c'est du sérieux vous êtes
présents l'un et l'autre nous avons bien
travaillé sur ces incitations à l'emploi
sur la gouvernance sur la VAE aussi je
j'insiste sur la vigilance que nous
aurons par rapport aux moyens pour la
VAE qui doit devenir une troisième voie
même titre que la forme nationale la
formation continue le financement du Gyp
la question des des jurys sur la
gouvernance je raffirme notre cap c'est
le paritarisme et le dialogue social et
c'est sur ce principe que doit se
construire france-travail c'est sur ce
principe que nous devons réformer je
pense compétences le déficit de France
compétences démontre qu'en matière de
bonnes gestion l'étatisation n'est pas
une assurance de bonne gestion bien
contraire les tatisations n'est pas la
solution et la libéralisation non plus
c'est il y a une troisième voie celle du
paritarisme et c'est notre cap pour
France travail mais aussi la réforme de
France compétences l'assurance chômage
les retraites à agir Carco le 1%
logement et donc France travail sera
regardé comme un symbole de ce point de
vue là un dernier mot sur l'inspection
du travail elle est en crise et pourtant
dans le monde où l'entrepreneuriat est
parfois un abus nous avons besoin d'une
inspection du travail forte et
l'augmentation de 2% des crédits avec
l'inflation que nous connaissons paraît
bien faible voilà mes chers collègues
pour conclure je veux dire notre
attachement à un service public de
l'emploi performant avec une approche
personnalisée le retour à l'emploi des
personnes éloignées depuis trop
longtemps de l'emploi avec tous les
métiers qui sont en tension le lit
chaque jour dans la presse et puis quand
on rencontre des professionnels et bien
un des grands défis de notre pays pour
notre pays et c'est pourquoi nous
voterons cette mission je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et maintenant la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Artano
pour le groupe RDS et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur
des ministres dans messieurs les
rapporteur mes chers collègues je tiens
d'abord à remercier les rapporteurs et à
saluer la qualité du travail du
rapporteur pour un vire de notre
collègue Frédéric puissant parce qu'il
n'est pas forcément aisé d'évaluer la
pertinence d'une enveloppe budgétaire
dans un contexte d'inflation persistante
et des défis considérables pour le
travail et l'emploi il faut donc prendre
en compte dans nos analyses c'est
nombreux inconnus pour l'année 2023
protéger les Français et aller vers le
plein emploi quels sont les ambitions du
gouvernement pour 2023 avec une hausse
de 6,7 milliards d'euros par rapport à
2022 on note un réel effort pour
dynamiser l'embauche des apprentis il
faut donc poursuivre ses efforts
déployés depuis 2017 pour parvenir au
plein emploi
en effet je reste persuadé que le
travail est un levier d'insertion
incontournable dans notre société je
tiens à saluer évidemment les
associations les entreprises et les
ateliers d'insertion qui œuvrent au
quotidien pour que chacun puisse
s'insérer et s'épanouir dans notre
société on se sent on ne peut que se
réjouir de la progression des crédits de
cette mission cette tendance aussi reste
indispensable pour mener à bien les
réformes nous ils ont à réduire les
inégalités d'accès à l'emploi et à
développer les compétences
professionnelles de tous les Français
cette hausse du budget de la mission
travail emploi doit tout de même être
relativisé car il faut prendre en compte
dans notre analyse la disparition du
programme cohésion de la mission plan de
relance
j'en reviens plus précisément au crédit
du programme 102 accès retour à l'emploi
qui sont en légère baisse soit 5% en
raison des prévisions de diminution du
nombre de bénéficiaires des allocations
de solidarité des personnes en fin de
droit à l'assurance chômage au sein du
même programme il faut souligner
l'augmentation des crédits du secteur de
l'IAE par l'intermédiaire du fond
d'inclusion pour l'emploi ce qui est en
soit une très bonne chose quelques mots
sur la traduction budgétaire du cuj créé
par la dernière loi de finances les 800
millions d'euros crédits prévus ne
devront donc permettre aux missions
locales et à Pôle Emploi d'accompagner
environ 300.000 jeunes pour l'année 2023
dont 200 000 nouveaux bénéficiaires ce
dispositif héritier du plan de relance
doit continuer de monter en puissance
afin de permettre aux jeunes les plus en
difficulté d'entrer de manière pérenne
sur le marché du travail
je note aussi une augmentation de 30
millions d'euros pour l'accompagnement
des publics les plus éloignés de
l'emploi ce qui est encouragé bien
évidemment mais je considère que les
crédits consacrés aux entreprises
adaptées pour les personnes en situation
de handicap reste encore insuffisants
je poursuis avec les crédits de
programme 103 l'accompagnement pour les
mutations économiques et développement
de l'emploi qui vise à soutenir les
actifs et les entreprises dans leur
phase de transition et de monter en
compétences on note que les crédits de
paiement de ce programme s'élève à 12,6
milliards d'euros contre 6 milliards
dont la loi de finances initiale 2022 la
principale hausse concerne évidemment
bien évidemment le soutien au
développement des contrats
d'apprentissage et de
professionnalisation cette hausse des
crédits s'explique naturellement par le
rapatriement des crédits dédiés à
l'activité partielle qui figurait
auparavant dont la mission plan de
relance
on fait un concernant France travail je
m'interroge sur la pertinence de cette
structure car les crédits que nous
sommes amenés à analyser vont-ils
réellement rééquilibrer les comptes
madame monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous indiquer quelle est la situation et
quelles ajustements sont envisagées pour
parvenir à l'équilibre budgétaire par
ailleurs la question de la gouvernance
de France compétence est toujours
pileuse qu'en est-il à ce stade dans
l'attente de ces réponses vous l'aurez
compris tout en restant vigilant le
groupe RDSE votre en grande majorité les
crédits de cette mission
et maintenant la parole est à Madame
Céline
pour les républicains et pour cette
minute
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues les crédits de la mission
travaillent et emploi sont examinés dans
un contexte bien particulier où il nous
faut respecter un savant jeu
d'équilibriste entre la maîtrise des
dépenses d'une part et l'indispensable
soutien aux politiques d'emploi de
l'autre le présent budget accompagne une
situation dans l'emploi globalement
favorable la France connaissante un
recul du taux de chômage à 7,4%
actuellement
cependant nous sommes toujours mal
classés au sein de l'Union européenne
surtout la croissance ne pourra que
reculer en 2023 sous les effets
conjugués de l'inflation et des
problèmes énergétiques ce qui devrait se
répercuter sur le marché du travail
la promesse présidentielle de parvenir
au plein d'emplois c'est ce quinquennat
semble donc malheureusement à ses
illusoires comme l'on soulignait nos
rapporteur les crédits de la mission
évoluent à la hausse mais celle-ci est à
relativiser car elle s'explique surtout
par la réintégration dans son périmètre
de dispositif porté en 2021 et 2022 par
le plan de relance notamment les aides à
l'apprentissage et l'activité partielle
en tenant compte des lois rectificatives
votées en 2022 les budgets de cette
année de l'année prochaine seraient même
très proches contrairement aux messages
diffusés par le gouvernement concernant
les réformes envisagées je voudrais
formuler plusieurs réserves et
interrogations monsieur le ministre vous
avez annoncé une réforme du service
public de l'emploi avec la création d'un
nouvel organisme France travail il
s'agit de simplifier les parcours en
mettant en commun les informations et
stratégies d'accompagnement notamment
avec un point d'entrée unique dans le
service public de l'emploi les
différents acteurs auditionnés au Sénat
ont exprimé leur réserves estimant le
projet de loi très flou ils ne dispose
d'aucun élément précis sur son périmètre
et son contenu une concertation a été
engagée mais elle manque de transparence
dans ses objectifs et elle n'associe pas
le Parlement nous serons donc
extrêmement vigilants pour éviter que
cette nouvelle structure ne se
transforme en usine à gaz ou ne
soumettent les différents opérateurs à
des contraintes inappropriées vous avez
dans un lancer par ailleurs une
expérience concernant les bénéficiaires
du RSA qui dépend précisément de la
création de France travail l'organisme
sera chargé de mettre en place un
contrôle et un accompagnement renforcé
nous sommes favorables un suivi qui soit
enfin efficace la Cour des comptes vient
en effet de pointer les défaillances du
dispositif d'accompagnement en matière
de retour à l'emploi la moitié des
allocataires du RSA le sont encore au
bout de quatre ans et 29% après 7 ans
un budget de 20 millions d'euros est
prévu pour le lancement de
l'expérimentation dans une dizaine de
territoires pilote sur 12 mois on peut
se demander si l'expérimentation puisse
généralisation pourront se conduire à
moyen constant sur le terrain
à l'image de nos rapporteurs je
souhaiterais faire part de notre
inquiétude concernant France compétences
structure créée en 2018 pour réformer la
formation professionnelle France
compétences a bénéficié de transfert de
trésorerie exceptionnel dans les deux
lois de finances rectificative de cette
année malgré cet apport c'est le vent à
4 milliards d'euros son déficites pour
être atteindre 3,4 milliards d'euros en
2022 la Cour des comptes salarin d'une
impasse financière selon ses propres
termes le déficit est clairement lié à
la réforme du financement de
l'apprentissage sous le précédent
quinquennat depuis 2020 les CFA sont
financés par les entreprises en fonction
du nombre de contrats signés et l'État
s'est substitué aux régions pour
compléter ce financement la
multiplication des contrats
d'apprentissage fait basculer France
compétences dans le rouge
les crédits que nous sommes une nouvelle
fois invités à voter pour rééquilibrer
ses comptes interrogent sur le
fonctionnement et la pertinence de la
structure notre groupe soutiendra donc
l'amendement de la rapporteur dans la
commission des affaires sociales
Frédéric puissat dont nous saluons la
qualité du travail et qui vise à réguler
les dépenses de France compétence de
même nous suivrons son avis éclairé pour
dégager des économies sur les crédits
affectés au pic celui-ci n'ayant pas
démontré son utilité en matière
d'insertion et de formation
professionnelle et devant prendre fin
l'année prochaine
l'économie totale réalisée serait ainsi
de 800 millions d'euros ces mesures sont
pleinement cohérentes avec notre
préoccupation de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques de l'État
je souhaiterais enfin évoquer la relance
de l'apprentissage je me réjouis que la
dynamique se poursuive avec une hausse
de 38% du nombre de contrats entre 2020
et 2021 le gouvernement prévoit la
signature de plus de 800 000 contrats
cette année contribuant à améliorer
l'emploi des jeunes ce succès est en
partie dû aux aides qui ont été versées
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire je
m'interroge donc sur l'éventuelle
suppression le 31 décembre prochain de
l'aide à l'embauche d'apprentis de plus
de 18 ans
cette aide exceptionnelle contribue à
relancer l'attractivité de nombreux
métiers je pense notamment à la filière
agricole 40% des agriculteurs ont plus
de 55 ans et partiront à la retraite
d'ici à 2030 alors que seul un départ
sur trois est remplacé les petites
structures agricoles ne pourront plus
recruter d'apprentis sans cette aide à
l'embauche qui couvre la première année
de salaire je tenais à rappeler cette
situation à la veille de concertation
menée avec les partenaires sociaux et
souhaiteraient avoir votre sentiment sur
ce point monsieur le ministre
le groupe la républicains votera ce
budget en augmentation avec les mesures
d'économique que nous avons indiqué
notre groupe souhaite que l'examen de la
loi de finances permettent de faire
bouger les lignes tracées par les
gouvernement nous visons ainsi un budget
maîtrisé tenant compte des difficultés
actuelles mais protégeant notre pays
d'une dette devenant abyssale protéger
les Français et leurs emplois passent
aussi et surtout par cette discipline je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
et la parole est maintenant à jouer le
guerrier ou pour le groupe des années
pendant et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues attendre le
plein emploi c'est à la fois un objectif
économique et social économique
évidemment car davantage d'emploi c'est
un accroissement d'activité
s'accompagnant d'une meilleure
intégration par le travail ceci elle
aussi parce qu'un accroissement
d'activités c'est davantage de recettes
publiques pour financer la solidarité ce
sont les entreprises qui nous
permettront d'atteindre cet objectif et
je l'espère d'ici la fin du quinquennat
il n'y a pas d'emploi durable que la
création de valeur ajoutée c'est d'abord
sur les entrepreneurs et les
travailleurs que nous comptons pour y
parvenir
mais la puissance publique peut et doit
aider à atteindre le plein emploi
notamment en facilitant l'intégration
des publics les plus éloignés du marché
du travail c'est levier d'action se
trouve dans la mission que nous
examinons aujourd'hui les crédits de la
mission travail emploi dépasse cette
année les 20 milliards d'euros ils
augmentent de près de 29 % par rapport à
la loi de finance initiale et c'est bien
sûr considérable mais cette eau
s'appelle plusieurs remarques la
première c'est l'effort de sincérité
budgétaire du gouvernement en effet les
crédits inscrits dans cette mission pour
2023 sont largement supérieurs à ceux
inscrit à la loi de finances initiale
pour 2022 mais pour autant ils sont
nettement inférieurs à ceux finalement
débloqué en 2022 après les deux projets
de loi de finance rectificative
c'est pourquoi si les seulement si en
cours d'année les crédits de la mission
ne sont pas significativement augmentés
par la voie d'un projet de loi de
finance rectificative alors le
gouvernement aura finalement maîtrisé la
dépense associée la deuxième remarque
répond à des interrogations exprimées
par plusieurs de nos collègues en effet
alors que la vocation des politiques
budgétaires dans cette mission et de
stimuler l'emploi on pourrait penser que
les crédits sont amenés à diminuer
lorsque la situation du marché du
travail s'améliore mais les situations
n'est pas si évidente et pour cause la
plupart des mécanismes déployés par le
gouvernement pour faciliter
l'intégration par le travail sont plus
structurelles que conjoncturelles
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont vocation à se
maintenir sans tenir compte de la
situation du marché de l'emploi cela
m'amène à ma troisième et dernière
remarque qui concerne l'apprentissage
nous sommes nombreux ici à soutenir
depuis longtemps l'apprentissage comme
vecteur d'intégration des jeunes au
marché du travail le gouvernement a mis
les bouchées doubles pour encourager les
entreprises à embaucher des jeunes et
les résultats sont nets le nombre
d'entrée en apprentissage a doublé entre
2019 et 2021 passant de 370 000 à 740
mille jeunes le montant des aides à
l'embauche de alternant est ainsi passé
de 1,3 milliards d'euros en 2020 à 4,5
milliards en 2021 sur ce point je
partage analyse notre apporteur spécial
Emmanuel Capu dont je tiens à saluer le
travail il faut à la fois reconnaître le
succès de l'apprentissage et poser la
question de l'efficacité de la dépense
publique le gouvernement engagé avec les
partenaires sociaux des négociations sur
ce sujet et cette dynamique de dialogue
me semble positive je l'ai dit d'emblée
le seul emploi durable c'est la création
de valeur ajoutée pour les entreprises
l'emploi aidé améliore les statistiques
du chômage mais il pèse sur les finances
publiques et masque la compétitivité
réelle du pays l'apprentissage doit donc
pas être une nouvelle forme d'emploi et
des avec des effets d'aubaines possibles
pour les entreprises
cependant monsieur le ministre j'espère
que Bercy ne cédera pas la tentation
d'une approche strictement budgétaire
pour évaluer le dispositif de
l'apprentissage beaucoup d'effets
positifs notamment au plan de la
cohésion sociale et de l'éducation des
jeunes n'apparaîtront jamais dans les
comptes mais sont extrêmement précieux
je souhaiterais enfin ajouter un mot sur
les mécanismes de soutien aux
entreprises adaptées contrairement au
dispositif financé par la mission qui
permettent l'intégration par le travail
et doivent répondre logique du marché
ces crédits répondent d'un impératif
éthique permettre aux personnes en
situation de handicap de trouver leur
place dans la société dit contribuer par
leur travail de se sentir utile au
quotidien tout cela rend notre société
plus humaine et plus équitable c'est
pourquoi je tiens à saluer
l'augmentation des dotations en faveur
de l'emploi des personnes handicapées à
hauteur de 467 millions d'euros soit une
progression de près de 9% par rapport à
2022 ces aides seront complétées comme
l'an dernier par une contribution de
l'agefip de 50 millions d'euros notre
groupe votera les crédit de cette
mission sous réserve de l'adoption des
amendements proposés par nos rapporteurs
spéciaux merci de votre attention merci
la parole est ensuite Madame Raymonde
pensée Monge pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues quelques
semaines seulement après que le
gouvernement est officialisé la
Contre-Réforme de l'assurance chômage
nous trouvons face à un texte qui amorce
sa mise en oeuvre ainsi 20 millions
d'euros sont alloués à l'expérimentation
France travail dont les contours et les
missions restent floues si ce n'est de
répondre à l'injonction du travail plus
et qui se met progressivement en place
sans que ni le Parlement ni les
partenaires sociaux ne soient pleinement
saisi du contenu du projet ce 49.3 de
l'expérimentation vise peut-être à nous
mettre nous et les partenaires sociaux
devant le fait accomplir lorsque la
convention tripartite Pôle Emploi est à
uneédique dont la reconduction est en
train d'être discutée prendra
définitivement fin elle se terminera
d'ailleurs sans que le gouvernement
n'ait à la hauteur de ses promesses
budgétaires soit lors de la signature de
la convention en 2015
milliards d'euros alors que le
financement est aujourd'hui de 1,2
milliards et la hausse des crédits à
louer cette année à Pôle emploi n'est
qu'un rattrapage d'un écosécutifs
d'austérité de baisse des effectifs
l'état transférant peu à peu la charge
du pôle emploi sur l'inédit donc au
détriment des prestations qui convient
alors de diminuer la pérennisation des
ETP accordée à Pôle emploi pour la mise
en oeuvre du contrat d'engagement jeune
en 2020 et qui explique la hausse
actuelle des crédits doit améliorer la
dégradation constante des conditions de
travail au sein de l'agence aussi les
écologistes s'opposeront à leur
réduction car selon les syndicats la
proportion de personnels en CDD à Pôle
Emploi serait passé de 5% environ en
2019 à 13% en 2021 avec de fortes
disparités locales puisque certains
sites peuvent atteindre jusqu'à 50%.
l'établissement chargé de l'emploi en
France diffuse le CDD comme
aussi en 2017 chaque conseiller avait en
moyenne en portefeuille 46 demandeurs
d'emploi on accompagnement global
aujourd'hui 54 et 336 en accompagnement
suivi aujourd'hui 406 de la vie générale
les réformes successives ont porté
atteinte à la sécurité des agents
provoquer des pertes de sens au travail
et une gestion parfois
erratique des dossiers du fait de
changement incessants de calcul des
indemnités malgré tout le gouvernement
se réjouit de la baisse du chômage en
partie en trompe l'oeil et baisse en
conséquence les crédits du programme 102
accepte accès et retour à l'emploi hors
de la vie même de lycée un tiers de la
hausse du taux d'activité mi 2022
résulte des contrats en alternance
notamment en apprentissage
soit des emplois hautement subventionnés
profitant largement selon la Cour des
comptes au plus diplômés et non et non
ou 1,5 millions de jeunes sans emploi ni
formations ces derniers dépendent en
réalité des contrats empoisonnent qui
malgré un certain succès avec près de
200000 contrats en 2022 restant nombre
insuffisant en projection 2023
et comme toute personne éloignée de
l'emploi il dépendent beaucoup des
emplois aidés comme les parcours en
poids compétences qui eux sont en
diminution de 20 000 passent de 12 à 6
mois réduisant ainsi leur durée totale
maximale à 18 mois cela sans explication
ni justification
de plus la baisse du chômage pour 2023
est une hypothèse assez hasardeuse qui
ne tient pas compte des travaux de
l'unédique prévoyant un tassement de la
progression des emplois salariés dès
l'année prochaine comme de l'OFCE qui
table sur une remontée du chômage
jusqu'en 2024 dans le contexte où la
réforme de l'assurance chômage aura pour
effet de rendre les fins de droit plus
précoce et de réaliser plusieurs
milliards d'économies la mission certes
présente des crédits en hausse mais
peut-être faussement car la hausse de la
mission 103 par exemple et du très
largement au transfert des crédits
dédiés à l'activité partielle qui
figurait auparavant dans la mission plan
de relance passant de 11,9 milliards
contre 7 au PLF 2023
ceci pour les autorisations d'engagement
et pareil pour les crédits de paiement
ces jeux budgétaires ne masquent pas les
insuffisances d'une politique de
l'emploi qui reste antisociale tournée
vers la baisse des droits des demandeurs
d'emploi en conséquence le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire ne
votera pas les crédits de cette mission
je vous remercie
déjà collègues la parole est maintenant
à Martin lévrier pour le groupe RDP
et pour 6 minutes
[Rires]
bien monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre Madame et
Monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire à cette tribune le plein emploi
n'est pas une utopie le taux de chômage
au sens du Bureau international du
Travail a baissé de 2,2 points depuis
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron pour
atteindre son niveau le plus bas depuis
15 ans
le gouvernement porte l'ambition du pén
emploi et les crédits dont la mission
travaillée emploi est dotée le démontre
ils atteignent un montant total de 20,29
milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement soit une hausse de 28% et
de 20,88 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement soit une hausse de 42,57%
. c'est eux près de 6,2 milliards
d'euros en crédit de paiement s'explique
majoritairement par des changements de
périmètre des dispositions jusque là
financées par le plan de relance à
l'instar de la prime à l'apprentissage
et d'une partie de l'activité partielle
font désormais l'objet d'un financement
de droit commun
notons qu'un périmètre comparable
l'augmentation est de 1,1 milliard
d'euros en crédit de paiement et
d'environ 1 milliard d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement dû à la
dynamique de compensation des
exonérations de cotisation qui présente
qui représente pardon un peu plus de 6
millions 600 millions d'euros par les
emplois créés en 2022 l'inscription de
350 millions d'euros au titre de la
partie formation du Front national pour
l'emploi et 50 millions d'euros pour les
financements de dispositifs de
transition collective
afin de bien mesurer la portée de ses
crédits les moyens les plus efficaces et
dans lisser les principes dans listés
par dans les principales modifications
par rapport à l'année précédente notons
le renforcement de la prévention en
santé au travail suite à la mise en
œuvre de la loi du 2 août 2021 je le
disais juste avant l'inscription en
droit commun de 350 millions d'euros au
titre du FNE formation et des
dispositifs de transition collective
jusque la financée dans le cadre du plan
de relance la poursuite du financement
du programme d'investissement dans les
compétences 2,5 milliards d'euros dont
1,6 milliards d'euros pour financer le
vote régional
du budget de l'insertion par l'activité
économique afin de financer une
augmentation de 700 de 7000 ETP en
structure d'insertion l'objectif du
gouvernement est en d'atteindre 240 000
bénéficiaires le renouvellement des
crédits pour l'accès des jeunes à
l'emploi avec l'objectif de 300000
contrats d'engagement jeune une aide aux
missions locales avec un budget de plus
de 630 millions d'euros
mes chers collègues le travail mené à
bien par les gouvernements qui se sont
succédés depuis cinq ans porte ses
fruits nous devons donc continuer selon
les mêmes principes et non chercher à
raboter arbitre rarement certaines
dépenses combattre le chômage pour
atteindre le plein emploi n'est pas une
charge c'est un investissement c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne pouvons
accepter le premier amendement de Madame
la rapporteur qui réduit les crédits à
hauteur de 850 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 600
millions pendant 800 oui exact 800 et
600 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement
quant au second
issu d'une proposition d'un rapport
France compétences face à une crise de
croissance il en détourne en partie le
sens si l'idée d'un reste à charge pour
certaines formations a été évoquée c'est
afin que les partenaires sociaux sont
non part et proposent des solutions
pertinentes cette démarche nous
paraissait plus cohérente même si c'est
amendement va dans la bonne direction
mes chers collègues je le redis dans ce
nouveau contexte qui casse les habitudes
de la gestion du chômage de masse nous
devons continuer à investir dans toutes
les solutions pertinentes pour atteindre
le plein emploi
avant de conclure je rappellerai les 8
chantiers identifiés comme prioritaire
par le ministère au cours des prochaines
années et pour lesquelles il nous faudra
travailler en bonne intelligence la
rénovation du service public de l'emploi
par la création de France de France
travail la réforme de l'accompagnement
des bénéficiaires du RSA et la meilleure
insertion des publics les plus éloignés
de l'emploi la poursuite du déploiement
du contrat d'engagement jeune le
perfectionnement de l'assurance chômage
l'amplification de la dynamique de
l'apprentissage la préparation des
actifs aux compétences de demain et bien
entendu le soutien de l'emploi des
seniors et la garantie de l'avenir de
notre système de retraite
mes chers collègues pour parvenir au
plan en plein emploi l'État est
pleinement mobilisé bien que très
attentif à la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques il donne au travers de ces
budgets de solides garantie et des
moyens sans précédent pour que chacun
puisse accéder à l'emploi ou si
maintenir et que chaque entreprise et
les compétences nécessaires au métier de
demain c'est donc bien naturellement que
le groupe RDPI votera les crédit de la
mission
Édouard
le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de la commission des
finances madame messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le ministre madame
la ministre chers collègues le travail
plutôt que l'assistanal le sens de
l'effort plutôt que le nivellement par
le bas le mérite l'équilibre des droits
et les devoirs voilà les valeurs que
notre groupe porte et assume dans cette
hémicycle et sur le terrain cela se
traduit par les propositions que nous
faisons sur cette mission et l'analyse
que nous en tirons les crédits qui je le
rappelle financent principalement des
dispositifs concurrents à la politique
de l'emploi et qui enregistre une très
forte augmentation il s'inscrivent dans
un contexte particulièrement favorable
qui doit être indéniablement salué en
effet la situation de l'emploi s'est
améliorée par rapport à fin 2019
l'emploi salarié a progressé 800 000
personnes et le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi a diminué de près de 400 000 la
dépense budgétaire portée par la mission
c'est alourdi mais d'autres dépenses
sont diminués notamment l'indemnisation
du chômage l'unedique sera en excédent
cette année pour la première fois depuis
donc la progression la masse salariale
elle se répercute évidemment sur les
recettes de l'État et des organismes de
protection sociale en outre les moyens
très importants ont été consacrés ces
trois ou quatre dernières années à des
dispositifs dont beaucoup étaient
antérieurs à la crise d'autres mises en
place durant la crise mais destinée à
être en partie pérennisé notamment en
direction des jeunes ou des chômeurs de
longue durée ainsi les moyens qui leur
sont alloués progressent de plus de 15%,
il est à noter la montée en charge du
contrat engagement jeune avec un
objectif de 300 000 pour 2023 les
premières données sur le déploiement des
CEJ sont d'ailleurs encourageantes s'il
est encore trop tôt pour mesurer son
effet sur l'insertion professionnelle
des jeunes les objectifs fixés
paraissent cohérents et exigeront
d'assurer la bonne articulation des CEJ
avec les autres dispositifs d'insertion
des jeunes en particulier dans le cadre
du projet France travail dont l'objectif
est d'harmoniser les actions
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi
l'inclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap par le travail est une
absolue nécessité et comme la commission
j'appelle à l'adoption de l'article
permettant de prolonger les
expérimentations favorisant l'emploi de
travailleurs handicapés par des
Entreprises Adaptées partagent également
les réserves du rapporteur quand à
l'opportunité de maintenir les emplois
francs dont les premières évaluations
n'ont pas permis de mesurer l'impact sur
l'emploi dans les qpv mais je suis
particulièrement favorable à la hausse
des compensations des exonérations de
cotisations sociales sur les entreprises
particulièrement en faveur des services
d'aide à domicile et la déduction des
heures supplémentaires dispositifs
départ dont les républicains sont à
l'origine les enjeux sur ces deux points
pour nos compatriotes sont majeurs le
premier dans un contexte de
vieillissement de la population et le
second dans le contexte économique que
nous connaissons enfin je tiens à me
féliciter du succès de l'apprentissage
qui est essentiel malgré le poids
financier qui représente il enregistre
une véritable dynamique positive avec
une hausse de 38% des contrats entre
2020 et 2021
c'est un atout pour notre jeunesse et un
dispositif plébiscité par nos
entreprises surtout dans nos territoires
ruraux néanmoins il est indéniable qu'il
nous faut réfléchir la soutenabilité du
financement qui représente un enjeu
majeur il repose sur la prise en charge
des contrats selon un niveau déterminé
par les branches professionnelles est
assurée par France compétences dont les
ressources sont principalement issues
des contributions des employeurs à la
formation professionnelle et à
l'apprentissage or depuis 2020 ces
dépenses de guichet dépassent largement
le produit des contributions des
employeurs et face à ce déséquilibre
chronique France compétences doit
régulièrement recourir à des emprunts de
court terme pour faire face à ses
besoins de trésorerie ainsi le PLF pour
2023 demande une enveloppe de 1,68
milliards d'euros pour l'établissement à
cette datation s'ajoute un ensemble de
mesures qui permettraient de limiter les
dépenses de l'opérateur pour conclure
permettez-moi deux opérations la
première concerne le CPF pour la
lisibilité et l'effectivité doivent être
améliorées des mesures de régulation de
des formations éligibles ont fort
justement été engagées par le contrôle
des certifications professionnelles la
lutte contre la fraude au CPF qui serait
renforcée par une proposition de loi en
cours de discussion constituerait un
levier supplémentaire dont les effets
sont toutefois difficiles à évaluer en
outre l'article 49 du PLF introduit à
l'Assemblée nationale propose que la
mobilisation du CPF par son titulaire
pour le financement d'une action de
formation fasse l'objet d'un mécanisme
de régulation dont les modalités sont
définies par décret il est souhaitable
de réguler les dépensiers au CPF afin de
recentrer le dispositif sur
l'employabilité des utilisateurs et sur
le développement des compétences à
finalité professionnelle je suis donc
favorable à l'amendement adopté
instaurant un plafonnement de la prise
en charge du coût de certaines
formations pour recentrer et rendre plus
efficace le dispositif je défends aussi
dans une proposition de loi déposée que
signée par de nombreux collègues de
mieux lutter contre le démarchage
téléphonique abusif qui touche
spécialement le CPF la seconde est de
rappeler que l'argent public ce n'est
pas de l'argent gratuit mais le fruit du
travail des Français du bon sens me
direz-vous et vous aurez raison ce qui
justifie d'ailleurs l'amendement notre
collègue Frédéric puissat ainsi dans
contexte économique et financier actuel
cela oblige l'État en particulier à
faire preuve d'exemplarités et
d'efficacité dans l'engagement des
dépenses à ce titre il serait sage qu'il
s'applique à lui-même les efforts qu'il
exigent des collectivités locales mieux
faire avec moins et devenu année après
année le lait motif forcé les
collectivités que les élus sur le
terrain en première ligne appelé avec
détermination et courage je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues et maintenant la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du sort il
serait du travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
cher Carole Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le professeur de budget que
nous vous présentons avec Carole
Grangeon augmente comme cela a été dit
de 4,5 milliards d'autorisation
d'engagement et de 6,2 milliards d'euros
en crédit de paiement entre le budget
initial pour 2022 et le budget initial
pour 2023 miss a été dit aussi en
premier par le rapporteur Breuillet
cette évolution est peu significative
pour deux raisons plusieurs dispositifs
étaient financés sur l'urgence et sur la
relance comme les aides à
l'apprentissage que nous maintenons et
la mission travaillée de plus de 7
milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et 2,7 milliards d'euros en
crédit de paiement à l'occasion de la
loi de finance rectificative du mois de
juin dernier
au total le budget du ministère
bénéficiera donc de 20,3 milliards
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement de
20,9 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement et avec un seul objectif
derrière ce chiffre la poursuite du
plein emploi et l'atteinte du plein
emploi ce budget est un emploi d'abord
parce qu'il traduit les effets de la
baisse du chômage ainsi les allocataires
de la location de solidarité spécifique
financée par l'État 180 000 de moins que
ce que nous redoutions l'année dernière
ce qui nous permet d'économiser 492
millions d'euros ce qui sera dû aussi
par une baisse des crédits de cette
action c'est une bonne nouvelle bonne
nouvelle parce que cette baisse du
nombre d'allocataires n'a pas n'a pas
été accompagné d'une augmentation du
nombre de bénéficiaires du RSA c'est
donc du retour à l'emploi et ainsi 156
000 demandeurs d'emploi de très longue
durée ont retrouvé le chemin de l'emploi
au cours de la dernière année
c'est aussi un budget de plein emploi
parce qu'il encourage l'emploi des
jeunes ainsi l'alternance mais Carole
Grandjean y reviendra voit ses crédit
augmenté de 3,5 milliards d'euros
consacré à l'aide à l'embauche
d'alternes c'est pour cette raison et
parce que nous connaissons cette
dynamique en matière d'apprentissage
d'alternance que le Président de la
République et le gouvernement ce sont
fixé un objectif d'un million
d'apprentis en 2027 c'est ce qui
explique la mobilisation du gouvernement
des services des opérateurs de l'emploi
certains considèrent que l'apprentissage
coûte très cher nous ne pensons que le
Pôle Emploi rapporte et que
l'apprentissage est un levier majeur
pour atteindre cet objectif de la même
manière le budget initial de l'État
soutient pour la première fois la
trésorerie de France compétences par
l'octroi d'une subvention de 1,7
milliards d'euros le soutien est même
supérieur à 2 milliards d'euros lorsque
l'on intègre la prise en charge par
l'État du versement aux régions des
crédits nécessaires au financement des
pactes régionaux dans le cadre du pic je
veux saluer les efforts la volonté de
régulation même si nous ne partageons
pas la méthode consistant à diminuer des
crédits tels que la Commission des
affaires final le propose et je veux
saluer le rapport sénatorial dont madame
l'a rapporteur est une des auteurs pour
nous aider nous accompagner sur le
chemin du rétablissement des comptes de
France compétences ce budget encourage
aussi le plein emploi parce qu'il
favorise les compétences pour développer
l'emploi d'aujourd'hui et l'emploi de
demain nous prévoyons dans ce budget 300
millions d'euros au titre du FNA
formation 50 millions d'euros au titre
dispositif de transition collective car
nous sommes convaincus qu'il faut former
pour réduire les tensions actuellement
visibles sur le marché du travail en
matière de recrutement mais aussi pour
développer les compétences
indispensables pour accompagner les
transitions de fonds de notre économie
dans le secteur de la santé mais je
pense bien évidemment aux transitions
énergétiques ou numériques je veux aussi
souligner que ce budget et le budget de
l'emploi pour tous et en particulier le
budget de celles et ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés de l'emploi c'est la
raison pour laquelle 2023 sera une année
transition marquée par l'installation
progressive de France travail vous avez
été nombreux à souligner votre curiosité
votre impatience de connaître la
maquette le détail de la création de
France travail sans répéter ce que j'ai
déjà dit le fait ça ne sera pas une
opération de fusion ou de rapprochement
de structure nous ne voulons pas
connaître l'embolie l'embolie connaît
connu au moment de la création de de
Pôle emploi il va maintenant plus de 10
ans mais cette maquette essaie de taille
seront présentées à l'occasion de la fin
de la préfiguration que nous avons
confié à Thibault Gulli en fin du mois
de décembre et le milieu du mois de
janvier dans ce contexte nous avons
préservé les moyens de Pôle emploi alors
même que le chômage a diminué et ainsi
en 2023 nous accorderons une subvention
d'un virgule 250 millions
1,250 milliards d'euros à Pôle Emploi
niveau subvention qui n'avait pas été
atteint depuis 2019 cela permet de
pérenniser les effectifs accorder à
l'opérateur pour la mise en oeuvre du
contrat engagement jeune cela permet de
poursuivre le déploiement du parcours de
mobilisation des demandeurs d'emploi et
le maintien de la mobilisation au
service des entreprises dans un contexte
de forte tension de recrutement c'est la
raison pour laquelle les effectifs de
Pôle Emploi resteront stables avec une
baisse limitée à 31tp sur un total de 48
850 voir 52 900 si l'on prend en compte
les emplois hors plafond pour
l'essentiel des CDD ainsi Pôle Emploi
est armé pour la bataille du plein
emploi en 2017 les recettes de Pôle
Emploi s'élevées à 5,3 milliards d'euros
hors pactes régionaux et ses actifs ces
effectifs à 49 918 personnes en 2023 les
ressources de Pôle Emploi seront de 6,5
milliards d'euros et ses effectifs
globaux de 52840p pourquoi est-ce que
nous maintenons ces moyens pourquoi
est-ce que nous augmentons la subvention
en faveur de Pôle emploi parce que nous
croyons au renforcement de
l'accompagnement pour le pour le plein
emploi c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que
nous avons aussi préservé par ailleurs
les crédits de lutte contre la pauvreté
ou les crédits accompagnants les
expérimentations de services publics de
l'insertion et de l'emploi avec en 2023
29 millions d'euros d'autorisation
d'engagement et 39 en crédit de paiement
en matière d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi des plus éloignés de l'emploi
je veux dire un mot de l'insertion par
l'activité économique d'abord pour
rappeler que ces trois dernières années
le budget de l'IAE a fortement augmenté
depuis 400 millions d'euros dans le
cadre du Pacte pour l'ambition de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
2023 il a aussi une année de
consolidation et nous maintenons
néanmoins
os à hauteur de 1,3 milliards d'euros
1,3 milliards d'euros pour l'insertion
par l'activité économique c'est un
chiffre qui n'avait jamais été atteint
et qui marque une augmentation des
crédits par rapport à ce qui sera
réalisé en 2022 réalisation inférieure à
la prévision puisque même ces structures
connaissent des difficultés de
recrutement qui peuvent expliquer ce le
fait que tous les crédits ne sont pas
consommés cela permettra de financer en
2023 plus de poste que le nombre de
postes financés réellement et
effectivement en 2022 je vais aussi
souligner que le pied pour favoriser la
formation des salariés en insertion et
lui non seulement prolongé doit
augmenter de 25% 2023 puisqu'il passe de
80 à 100 millions d'euros
toujours pour aller vers le Pôle emploi
et permettre l'emploi de tous je tiens à
souligner devant vous le fait que les
entreprises adaptées bénéficieront pour
ce qui les concerne de plus de 500
millions d'euros donc 15 millions de
reconduction du fond d'accompagnement et
transformation des entreprises adaptées
nous allons aussi dans le même temps
poursuivent les efforts pour les jeunes
éloignés du marché du travail et nous
reconduisons l'objectif de 300000
bénéficiaires de contrats engagement
jeune pour l'année prochaine avec
l'accompagnement nécessaire ce qui
signifie
1,76 milliards d'euros qui sont inscrits
au projet de loi de finances pour ce
faire enfin je tiens à rappeler à
souligner que les contrats aidés restent
un outil traditionnellement utilisé dans
les politiques de l'emploi en 2023 le
nombre de contrats aidés diminuera pour
le secteur marchand et c'est un point
que nous assumons le marché du travail
va mieux et d'autres dispositif de
soutien à l'emploi se développe par
ailleurs ainsi nous prévoyons
31150 Cie pour 2023 contre 53200 en 2022
par contre nous prévoyons un total de
80000 pecs les contrats des contrat aidé
pour le secteur public contre 7700 en
2022 nous savons que ces contrats sont
particulièrement utiles aux
collectivités locales au-delà de ces
grandes priorités et de ces grandes
dignes d'action je souhaite aussi
souligner que le plein emploi est aussi
le bon emploi c'est la raison pour
laquelle le programme 111 améliorer la
qualité de l'emploi et des relations du
travail sera augmenté de 16 millions
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement et
de 18 millions d'euros en crédit de
paiement notamment pour accompagner la
modernisation des services de prévention
de santé au travail enfin pour mettre en
oeuvre ces politiques le ministère peut
compter sur des agents dévoués engagés
grande qualité en 2023 pour la première
fois depuis plus de 10 ans les effectifs
du ministère augmentent avec un schéma
en os de 60 TP ce qui permettra de
renforcer d'une part les services du
ministère notamment anti du renforcement
du pilotage des politiques publiques et
de la réinternalisation de mission de
prestataires externes cela permettra
d'accompagner la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques et de gérer notamment les
demandes de dérogation au droit du
travail en matière d'organisation des
Jeux et de présence des entreprises
prestataires
cela permettra aussi
d'accorder des moyens nécessaires aux
délégués ministériels à l'encadrement
supérieur de l'État entre 2011 et 2021
le schéma d'emploi était négatif
d'environ 180 FTP par an en moyenne il a
été stabilisé en 2022 à zéro je dois
cependant souligner pour la clarté des
débats et le plafond d'emploi et lui en
baisse de 188 équivalentes en plein par
rapport à 2022 pour s'établir à 7773
équivalentes cela s'explique par le
maintien obtenu des renforts
exceptionnels dans les services
déconcentrés qui devaient disparaître en
2023 et que nous maintenons pour partie
la détruit sera donc progressive ce qui
nous permettra pour les services du
ministère du Travail de l'absorber plus
facilement que si cette moyen avait été
supprimés en une seule fois ainsi 105
équivalentin sur les 210 sont conservées
au titre de l'accompagnement des
restructurations économiques et 120
équivalentes en plein sur 160 sont
maintenus au titre des mesures de
correction en matière de mise en oeuvre
de la nouvelle organisation territoriale
de l'État j'en reste là pour céder la
parole à Carole Grandjean sur les
questions de formation et
d'apprentissage je veux simplement pour
conclure remercier les trois rapporteurs
spéciaux du Sénat ainsi que l'ensemble
des sénateurs membres des deux
commissions qui ont examiné ces textes
pour la qualité de leur travail et je
crois la richesse et la sincérité de nos
échanges
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre du Travail du plan d'emploi et
de l'insertion chère Olivier madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales messieurs les rapporteurs
madame la rapporteur pour avis mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs le budget que
nous vous présentons aujourd'hui
encourage pleinement
l'emploi des jeunes l'emploi de long
terme parce qu'il encourage aussi
l'alternance ce sont 3,5 milliards
d'euros qui sont investis en crédit de
paiement et 2,3 milliards d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement qui sont
consacrés dans ce budget initial aux
aides à l'embauche d'alternant c'est une
somme importante que nous assumons car
c'est un investissement à la fois dans
l'éducation des jeunes et dans les
compétences des entreprises le président
de la République
effectivement et le gouvernement sont
fixés un objectif d'un million
d'apprentis parents d'ici à 2027 nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés vers
l'objectif de faire en fin de la France
une nation de l'apprentissage à tous les
niveaux de qualification et dans toutes
les entreprises il est clair comme vous
l'avez indiqué Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs que le développement
d'apprentissage a conduit à une hausse
des dépenses et un déséquilibre
financier de France compétences dont le
financement à l'alternance s'élève à
plus de 10 milliards d'euros je tiens à
le dire nous assumons car les résultats
sont sans appel le taux d'insertion dans
l'emploi a fortement contribué à
diminuer le taux de chômage des jeunes
sur ce point l'apprentissage est une
réussite forte notamment pour les moins
qualifiée d'entre nos jeunes et nous
constatons qu'effectivement 72% des
jeunes trouvent un emploi durable suite
à leur apprentissage nous avons appliqué
dès cet été des mesures de régulation
des dépenses en concertation avec les
branches professionnelles qui a conduit
à un mouvement général mais non uniforme
de baisse des niveaux de prise en charge
des contrats d'apprentissage à la fin de
les rapprocher des coûts observés
l'objectif n'était pas adapté une
stricte mesure d'économie mais bien de
ramener les niveaux de financement des
contrats au juste prix celui constaté
dans les CFA par le biais de l'analyse
de leur comptabilité analytique enfin
ensuite les primes exceptionnelles de
l'État décidé dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire et qui ont permis de soutenir
la formation des jeunes arrive à
échéance à la fin de l'année 2023 et
vous l'avez rappelé mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et donc des
concertations sont en cours avec les
partenaires sociaux en vue d'un
calibrage plus adapté pour la suite en
outre nous souhaitons soutenir la
trésorerie de l'opérateur et pour cela
le gouvernement octroyé deux milliards
d'euros en PLFR de fin de gestion au
bénéfice de France compétences ce
montant s'ajoute au 2,7 milliards
d'euros déjà octroyés par l'État en 2021
sur la LFI 2021 au 2 milliards d'euros
ouvert en 2022 par le PLFR 2022 de cet
été et 1,7 milliards d'euros qui est
proposé d'ouvrir en PLF 2023 2 milliards
d'euros de soutien avec la
rebudgétisation de la moitié des pactes
régionaux
je voudrais mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs revenir à l'instant sur le
compte personnel de formation
la dépense 2022 sera stabilisée par
rapport à la dépense 2021 à 2,7
milliards d'euros environ alors qu'elle
avait fortement augmenté en 2020 et 2021
c'est donc en cohérence avec nos
objectifs ambitieux pour la jeunesse et
en responsabilité vis-à-vis de France
compétences que l'État agit l'article 49
adopté à l'Assemblée nationale et que
Madame et Messieurs les rapporteurs vous
avez souhaité préciser par amendement
présente un mécanisme de régulation qui
vient compléter l'ensemble des mesures
déjà mises en place par le gouvernement
pour mieux orienter les dépenses
relatives au CPF et combattre la fraude
en effet les mesures de régulation par
la qualité de l'offre du catalogue le
nettoyage des formations créations
d'entreprise et les premières mesures de
lutte contre la fraude et ont largement
contribué je pense également à la
proposition de loi porter par Monsieur
le Sénateur Martin lévrier qui vise à
lutter contre les démarchage abusifs et
les fraudes qui vous sera bien très
bientôt soumise
enfin mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais avoir un dernier
mot sur la formation au métier d'avenir
car ce budget encourage l'emploi
d'aujourd'hui mais également de demain
pour faire face aux nouveaux enjeux de
formation des salariés le ministère a
obtenu une nouvelle enveloppe au titre
du fnoformation et du dispositif Transco
à hauteur de 350 millions en
autorisation d'engagement et 160
millions d'euros en granny de paiement
en 2023 le FNEF formation doit permettre
de poursuivre l'effort engagés en 2020
2021 et 2022 afin notamment
d'accompagner l'adaptation des
compétences des salariés de nos
entreprises vers la transition
écologique de poursuivre la
digitalisation et de favoriser la
souveraineté économique et énergétique
le dispositif transition collective
permet aux salariés qui subit des
conséquences des mutations économiques
de s'orienter vers les secteurs porteurs
et aux entreprises dans les emplois sont
fragilisés d'accompagner leurs salariés
dans cette transition en évitant des
départs contraints il y a un enjeu fort
à le faire reconnaître par les acteurs
et c'est le rôle que nous avons confié
aux délégués à l'accompagnement des
reconversions professionnelles merci à
chacun pour le travail que vous avez
effectué sur la préparation de ces
discussions et je vous propose
effectivement que nous puissions
démarrer le démarrage de discussion des
amendements merci à tous merci madame la
ministre
nous allons en effet procéder à l'examen
examendement portant sur les caddy la
mission
je rappelle que pour cette mission la
conférence est président à fixé une
durée maximum de deux heures 45 ce qui
veut dire que nous devons avoir terminé
à 12h45
à défaut il y a donc 27 amendements à
défaut la mission seul le débattieuses
amendements se poursuivrait à la fin de
la semaine ou la semaine prochaine
nous commençons à l'article nous
commençons par l'amendement 377 de
Madame la rapporteur
bien merci monsieur le Président alors
j'espère en prenant un peu de la hauteur
arriver à convaincre tous les miss
cycles de l'intérêt de cet amendement
nous convenons tous ce que la mission
travaille emploi s'inscrit dans le PLF
2023 jusque là pas de difficulté nous
avons tous écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention le FMI qui nous demande de
réduire les déficits publics nous avons
tous écouté avec attention le rapporteur
général du budget qui demande à ce que
l'État finalement aligne ses propos avec
en tout cas soit cohérent avec ce qu'il
dit c'est à dire que dès lors qu'il
demande aux collectivités de faire un
effort il s'assigne les mêmes objectifs
à partir de là et quand on regarde la
mission travaille un peu alors on peut
tarde les chiffres dans tous les sens je
vous ai écouté les uns et les autres moi
quand je suis sur le terrain je compare
BP à BP et CAAC et quand je compare LFI
2022 à PLF 2023 je constate quand même
plus 6 milliards d'euros entre ces deux
entre cette année à partir de là
ce que propose cet amendement il propose
simplement de réduire de contribuer à
cet effort en réduisant le pic de 500
millions d'euros c'est 500 millions
d'euros correspondent exactement à la
sous-exécution des trois premières
années et il le conforte également le
précise également que nous pourrions
effectivement réduire de 300 millions
d'euros le la somme que nous apportons à
France compétence alors même que nous
laissons un milliard trois pour France
compétences alors même que nous venons
de mettre en juillet 2 milliards pour
France compétences alors même que
nouveau nom de mettre en octobre 2
milliards pour France compétences à
partir de là cet amendement est
finalement un effort collectif qui est
demandé à tous aux déficit public et
c'est également un j'allais dire un
amendement de cohérence parce que quand
nous sommes sur le terrain et que nous
sommes contraints de voter des budgets
que nous avons beaucoup de mal à voter
au niveau des collectivités locales je
pense qu'il serait compliqué très
facilement de laisser passer ces sans un
moment donné contribuer à cet effort de
solidarité la vie du gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président
je comprends évidemment l'objectif qui
est posé par notre collègue puissant sur
la réduction de la dépense et la
commission des affaires sociales sur la
réduction des dépenses et des crédits je
la partage parfaitement et la commission
des finances partage cet objectif cet
amendement présente à mon avis trois
inconvénients majeurs et manque sa cible
la première inconvénient c'est que la
commission des finances a adopté les
crédits sans réserve et donc il est en
incohérence avec la position adoptée par
la commission des finances ça ne veut
pas dire que nous n'avons pas émis des
réserves sur des inquiétudes que nous
partageons sur le sur le déficit de
France compétence mais ça veut dire que
nous pensons qu'il faut vos décès voter
ses crédits tels qu'ils sont et deux
autres inconvénients c'est que 1
évidemment il y a des réductions
liée à l'apprentissage à réaliser nous
partageons aussi cet objectif les
travaux sont commencés la concertation
la ministre vient de le rappeler sont
commencé cependant ça ne portera pas ces
fruits cette année puisque les crédits
dans les contrats de cette année qui
sont qui seront signés avant la fin de
l'année ne sont pas concernés donc les
300 millions de diminutions des crédits
pour France compétences sont une
mauvaise une fausse bonne idée puisque
au contraire la commission des finances
considèrent que le fait d'inscrire dès
le début 1,7 milliards en LFI apparaît
beaucoup plus sincère puisque mes chers
collègues faut pas se leurrer à la fin
de l'année les dépenses elles seront là
et ma craintes pourraient tout à fait
honnêtes avec vous c'est que ce 1,7
milliards ne suffisent pas et la
troisième raison pour laquelle cet
amendement me paraît manquer sa cible
c'est le fait que l'on réduise de 500
millions d'euros le pic certes les
crédits ne sont pas intégralement
consommés mais c'est la fin d'un cycle
nous sommes tous favorables au pic et
cela risquerait de pénaliser les
conseils régionaux qui sont
attributaires en tous les cas qui sont
qui utilisent ce pic et qui le mettent
qu'il les développe sur le terrain c'est
la raison pour laquelle c'est une bonne
idée mais il me semble que ça rate sa
cible donc je vous propose je vous
rappelle la vie de la commission des
finances qui est un avis défavorable la
Bible
alors je rappelle la vie de la
commission des finances qui vient d'être
adopté en commission ce matin vous ne
deviez pas être là ce matin mon cher
collègue mais la vie de la commission
des finances qui a été validée c'est
c'est un avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement
restons calme
merci merci monsieur le Président
simplement sur cette amendement de
madame le rapporteur pour ce qui
concerne l'évolution du budget du
ministère et son enveloppe global je
partage le fait qu'il y ait 6,5
milliards d'euros d'augmentation des
crédit paiement mais comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire la périmètre
constance c'est beaucoup plus comparable
que 6,5 milliards d'euros la marche
n'est pas aussi haute et en cela je
reprends totalement l'explication qui a
été donnée par Monsieur Garrido tout à
l'heure pour dire que les crédits ne
sont pas en augmentation aussi
importante que ça en tout cas quand on
regarde le réaliser par rapport à la
prévision pour 2023 surtout deux
éléments sur le fond de l'amendement
d'abord pour ce qui concerne France
compétences nous faisons le choix
d'apporter de la trésorerie pour éviter
toute forme de rupture ça ne nous
empêche pas de mettre en oeuvre des
politiques de rationalisation nous avons
conduit la première vague de diminution
du niveau de prise en charge des coûts
de formation nous avons une proposition
de loi qui a été adoptée à l'Assemblée
nationale qui va permettre d'avoir de
nouveaux outils de régulation nous avons
prévu et cela fait l'objet d'autres
suffisamment la possibilité d'indiquer
modérateur et nous travaillons sur la
rationalisation c'est un chantier suivi
par Carole grangeant tout
particulièrement pour faire en sorte
d'amener progressivement France
compétences à revenir vers l'équilibre
et nous considérons que la diminution
vous proposez pourrait être dangereuse
pour la trésorerie de France compétences
et le paiement des frais de formation au
CSA au CFA deuxième point concerne le
pic nous a offert un effort de
rationalisation du pic puisque 2023 et
de là aussi une année transition en
tenant compte des niveaux de
consommation en tenant compte aussi et
d'un engagement pris par le gouvernement
il y a quelques mois concernant la
reconduction de la totalité des crédits
affectés à la part régional du pic ce
qu'on appelle parfois les prix qu'on
n'est pas actes régionaux surtout nous
avons pris connaissance du rapport du
comité scientifique d'évaluation du pic
qui montre que le pic permet une
augmentation du taux d'emploi 10 points
de 57 à 67% en population générale par
les formations qu'il permet il permet
une augmentation du taux d'emploi pour
les bénéficiaires qui sont âgés de plus
de 50 ans de 33 à 52% ce qui est
considérable c'est une bonne nouvelle il
a permis l'entrée en formation de 4
millions 600 000 personnes entre 2018 et
2021 ce qui représente une augmentation
par rapport à la période 2010-2015 de
460 000 personnes formées de plus chaque
année et les deux tiers des entrants
sont considérés comme vulnérables aux
risques de chômage de longue durée là
aussi c'est une bonne nouvelle et enfin
le Pic a aussi permis d'augmenter de 120
200 000 le nombre de formations
préqualifiantes de préparation des
formations qualifiantes pour accompagner
les plus éloignés donc pour toutes ces
raisons la vie du gouvernement et
défavorable à cet amendement de
réduction des crédits de France
compétences et du pic
je vais je vais demander à ce que tu as
un public et Monsieur bachel à la parole
pour expliquer son vote
merci monsieur le président madame
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
alors c'est pas tout à fait vrai que la
commission des finances c'est parce que
le rapporteur a donné un avis
rapidement en tout début de séance que
on a passé l'ensemble des choses donc
faut quand même pas confondre et faut
pas trop tordre toujours le règlement
parce que sinon on peut être Captieux
mais c'est pas forcément ce qui est
souhaitable dans cette hémicycle je
reviens sur les propositions de Frédéric
puissant dans son amendement que je
soutiens évidemment comme nous l'avons
dit dans les interventions du groupe les
républicains
d'une part il y a des crédits non
consommés
donc ça il faut quand même en te dire
compte un jour dans le vrai budget et
après moi j'ai bien entendu mail Capu
qui nous dit mais finalement il faudra
encore en rajouter dans
pour France compétence il y a un moment
ça suffit on peut pas continuer comme
cela notamment parce que la vérité il
faudrait peut-être la dire aussi sur
l'apprentissage très fortement c'est que
ça profite aux étudiants du supérieur
et on est en recherche là-dessus de
compétences très vite mais c'est dans le
supérieur que ça profite d'abord
osez dire le contraire faudra vous le
voir en le prouver avec des chiffres
très clairs et sur de nombreuses années
et on est toujours sur des problèmes qui
n'ont pas avoir avec de l'argent pour
les ceux qui sont les moins diplômés car
là c'est bien souvent les normes du
travail qui empêchent un apprenti de
commencer quand vous êtes pâtissier vous
pouvez pas commencer quand vous êtes
apprenti à 16 ans à 5h du matin alors
que les pâtisseries commencent à 5h du
matin voilà des exemples sérieux qu'il
faut mettre aussi en oeuvre ce n'est pas
que du budgétaire j'en ai bien
conscience mais je suis sûr que vous
allez y travailler mais en tout cas on
ne peut pas continuer à rajouter des
milliards et des milliards à France
compétences uniquement pour se faire
plaisir
je suis donc monsieur Bruyer monsieur le
rapporteur
je tiens à préciser deux choses la
première chose c'est que c'est un avis
des deux rapporteurs validé ce matin en
commission chers Jérôme
ma deuxième ma deuxième remarque c'est
que il y a bien sur l'apprentissage un
bénéfice plus grand pour les catégories
de
d'étudiants à haut niveau de formation
mais il y a aussi un progrès sur
l'ensemble des catégories y compris les
bacs -2 et bac moins 3 et une
reconnaissance de l'apprentissage qu'à
mon avis il convient de souligner et de
soutenir ma troisième remarque c'est
pour dire qu'au fond à titre personnel
je préfère parfois un excédent possible
et la sincérité un déficit masqué
donc je suis saisi d'une demande de nous
pardon
monsieur Savary
simplement une réflexion par rapport à
l'amendement proposé et ce qui nous a
motivé au niveau de la commission des
affaires sociales proposer une réduction
parce que on est dans un souci
d'équilibre budgétaire et d'ailleurs le
gouvernement semble les sembler partager
ce souci puisque Gabriel Attal n'a pas
cessé de nous dire de tous les débats de
la semaine dernière ah ben vous faites
parfois des dépenses supplémentaires
vous ne me proposez jamais des
réductions de dépenses et quand on
propose une réduction de dépenses on
nous dit c'est pas la bonne il faudrait
mettre un peu de cohérence dans tout
cela et je pense qu'effectivement s'il y
a du comparatif
contaministratif comme la souligner le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales comparatif entre 2022 2023 qui
a des possibilités de ne pas
tout de suite
budgété tout cet effort budgétaire il
sera peut-être éventuellement autant d'y
revenir à travers un PDF rectificatif
c'est tout à fait légitime qu'on une
chose de résolution des dépenses
publiques je tenais le souligner
donc cette fois-ci nous allons procéder
au scrutin public je rappelle que la vie
de la commission défavorable celui du
gouvernement également il va être
procédé au scrutin dans les conditions
du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
343 exprimé 331 pour l'amendement de 101
contre 130 amendements et donc adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 66 madame
ses collègues je me suis Periot qui le
présente merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre le 25 25 septembre
2017 le Premier ministre annonçait le
lancement d'un plan d'investissement
dans les compétences piques ayant
vocation favoriser l'insertion dans
l'emploi des jeunes et le retour des
demandeurs d'emploi sur le marché du
travail aurait aussi le niveau de
qualification
doté de 13,8 milliards d'euros sur la
période 2018-2023 le pic de ainsi
permettre la formation la compagnement
de 2 millions de jeunes et de demandeurs
d'emploi supplémentaires tout en
accélérant
par l'investissement la transformation
du système de formation continue afin
d'évaluer la réalisation du pic un
comité scientifique indépendant a vu le
jour doté d'un budget de 18 millions
d'euros sur la même période soit 3,5
millions d'euros annuels
crédits affectés à l'évaluation du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences ou
semblent aujourd'hui disproportionné par
exemple en comparaison avec les crédits
qui ont été affectés à l'évaluation du
plan de relance
en effet le comité d'évaluation du pic
et doté d'un budget de 9 fois plus
important que celui du plan de relance
ce qui est manifestement selon nous
excessif c'est pourquoi nous proposons
un amendement pour un réajustement afin
que les moyens soient affectés au plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
plutôt qu'à son évaluation merci
[Musique]
alors monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
effectivement de 3,5 millions d'euros de
crédit pour évaluer 15 milliards d'euros
3 milliards par an à peu près en moyenne
donc ça nous paraît raisonnable en
proportion surtout le travail du conseil
scientifique est un travail assez
méticuleux puisqu'il doit examiner non
seulement la mise en oeuvre des actions
nationales du pic mais aussi des actions
régionales et donc il y a autant de
programmes régionaux que de région par
définition avec des actions qui sont
extrêmement nombreuses et qui
nécessitent d'aller regarder cordes par
corps que les bénéficiaires l'impact sur
le taux d'emploi et de m'aider le
travail rétrospectif et statistiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle et malgré
des efforts qui sont faits par les
services en charge le budget de plus de
3 millions d'euros 3 millions 5 et tout
à fait nécessaire et ça permet
d'éclairer les travaux du Parlement
comme du gouvernement avec le rapport du
comité scientifique remis chaque année
le rapporteur l'ADIL a été remis l'année
dernière donc ça nous demande de retrait
son véritablement des crédits dont nous
avons besoin et qui sont utiles pour
mener ce vrai travail d'évaluation y
compris pour préparer le pic poste 2023
puisque nous sommes dans une année de
transition et que la la transition que
j'évoque en 2023 doit nous permettre de
décider quels sont les volumes que l'on
veut investir dans les compétences à
partir 2024
je souhaiterais qu'on puisse voter sur
ce délibération qui porte sur cet
amendement qui porte sur donc une
proposition de réduction ou de
rééquilibrage eu égard encore une fois à
l'écart de l'évaluation qui est portée
dans le cas du plan de relance par
rapport à cette opique donc nous pensons
que il y a vraiment là à la matière à
rééquilibrage à trouver monsieur
rapporteur défavorable je me vois
l'amendement 66 avec la vie défavorable
du gouvernement et de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre
abstention et pas adoptée ensuite de 612
présenté par Madame
jasmin qui a la parole Président
Monsieur et Madame la Ministre c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste vide à
rendre effective
la 46 jeunes universel
parce qu'il faut vraiment que ce soit
universel
en donnant des moyens aux missions
locales d'atteindre l'objectif
prévu pour tous ceux tous les jeunes qui
ne sont ni en étude ni un emploi ni en
formation soit un véhicule 5 millions de
jeunes madame la ministre vous venez de
dire que vous avez des objectifs
ambitieux donc je crois que c'est un
amendement permettra de prendre en
compte l'ensemble des jeunes concernés
en effet en 2019 un véhicule 5 millions
de jeunes
âgés de 16 à 25 ans n'ont ni emploi ni
formation et ne sont pas en études
d'après les données de l'INSEE environ
1,2 millions de jeunes sans emploi ni
formation ni étude n'ont donc pas accès
aux garantie jeunes que vous prévoyez
soit quatre jeunes éligibles sur cinq
dans ces conditions les effets d'annonce
et les effets de langage doivent se
traduire par la réalité merci
la commission monsieur le rapporteur oui
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
un avis défavorable vous avez compris
c'est un amendement à 2,5 milliards
d'euros
qui est pas très clair dans son
dispositif que on multiplie par 5 les
moyens alloués aux missions locales or
en réalité de ce que je comprends c'est
que ce sont les allocations qu'on
voudrait multiplier par 5 le nombre
d'allocataires donc c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose que les missions
locales elles accompagnent les jeunes
elles mettent en place aussi un
engagement d'une quinzaine d'heures de
travail il faut d'activité minimale et
puis il y a aussi le le bénéfice de la
location mais là l'amendement confond
les deux et puis vous l'avez compris en
fait l'idée c'est d'avoir un RSA jeune
or la vie de la commission est
défavorable sur ces 2,5 milliards
gouvernement
jamais où vous seront de moi avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
était absent il est pas adopté
610 madame monsieur
le Président donc c'est amendement vise
à garantir que les crédits fléchés vers
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
augmente au rythme de l'inflation en
effet le gouvernement propose une baisse
de 21% des crédits de cette même action
soit presque 500 millions d'euros
supprimés une telle coupe drastique
n'est nulle part expliquée dans le
projet annuel de performance mis à
disposition du Parlement il convient
donc de garantir la stabilité de ces
crédits une fois retirer l'effet de
l'inflation tel est l'objet du
présentement merci Monsieur rapporteur
c'est une demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre
défavorable la baisse des crédits sur ce
programme s'explique par la diminution
du nombre d'allocataires de la SS ce qui
est plutôt une bonne nouvelle je ne
pense pas que le maintien d'un haut
niveau de bénéficiaire de la SS soit le
signe d'une bonne politique de l'emploi
ce sont des bénéficiaires de la science
chômage en tout cas de la location
spécifique de solidarité qui retourne à
l'emploi donc c'est une très bonne
nouvelle c'est pour ça que nous avons
réajusté les crédits en ce sens
je me vois
il est retiré je précise que c'est ça la
clé pas clair que le précédent n'a pas
été adopté
ensuite 719 Madame A pour sauve madame
merci monsieur le Président notre
amendement d'appel visa bondé de 200
millions d'euros les crédits pour
l'enseignement professionnel public le
président de la République a annoncé la
réforme de l'enseignement professionnel
ce qui suscite aussi des inquiétudes
légitimes de la part des enseignants qui
craignent de voir l'alternance et
l'apprentissage devenir la priorité au
détriment de l'enseignement
professionnel nous nous refusons cette
mise en concurrence nous pensons que les
deux sont nécessaires mais bien sûr nous
refusons surtout la casse de
l'enseignement professionnel qui comme
vous le savez mes chers collègues
forment les citoyennes et les citoyens
donnent des bases techniques solides
pour lui substituer de la formation
professionnelle au gré des besoins des
employeurs sans socle théorique ça n'est
pas donc ce que nous défendons et c'est
pourquoi nous nous proposons de diminuer
200 millions d'euros les crédits pour
abonder dans le sens de ce que nous
défendons il est bien entendu aussi et
j'en profite en
cet amendement que en général au niveau
de mon groupe le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste nous
sommes pas tellement sur ce jeu
d'enveloppes ou finalement on retire
d'un côté pour alimenter de l'autre
comme si les les enveloppes sont fixées
une bonne fois pour toutes c'est un peu
un jeu de déshabillé Paul pour habiller
Jacques et c'est vraiment pas dans la
conception donc jusqu'à présent nous ne
faisions pas tellement d'amendements ce
sens mais je pense que c'est aussi une
façon c'est pour ça que c'est un
amendement d'appel d'attirer votre votre
attention sur l'importance de maintenir
l'enseignement professionnel sa qualité
et son encadrement la commission
qui n'a pas lieu d'être dans nos débats
puisqu'il relève pas de la mission
travail emploi donc c'est une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable monsieur
le ministre madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs même
si je salue l'engagement qui est le
vôtre pour accompagner les lycées
professionnels et leur réussite et bien
sûr nous partageons cette volonté et
vous le savez nous sommes en train de
préparer aussi une les conditions d'une
réforme qui donnera tous les moyens au
lycée professionnel d'être
d'accompagner la meilleure réussite de
l'ensemble des élèves et de favoriser
les conditions d'enseignement pour les
professeurs même si nous poursuivons
comme vous cet objectif il s'agit pour
nous de travailler en complémentarité
avec la voix de l'apprentissage et la
proposition que vous faites au travers
d'une mobilité des fonds entre la voie
de l'apprentissage et celle du lycée
professionnel pour nous n'est pas dire
n'est pas pertinent dans la mesure où la
voix de l'apprentissage reste une voie
de réussite que nous souhaitons
continuer à soutenir et nous souhaitons
également demain préparer les conditions
de la réussite du lycée professionnel
vous savez d'ailleurs que dans le lycée
professionnel nous avons 6 une
augmentation de 42% en deux ans et que
donc l'un et l'autre modèle ne s'oppose
pas à notre avis bien sûr nous
travaillerons demain ensemble sur cette
réforme du lycée professionnel nous
avons engagé des discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux lancer des groupes
de travail continuons évidemment à
construire cette cette perspective de
réforme qui sera appliquée
progressivement et dont l'ensemble des
modalités reste à construire ensemble
donc un avis défavorable retrait ou avis
défavorable
oui je veux particulièrement remercier
la ministre pour son effort
d'explication et le fait que ça permet
de montrer quel est l'objectif du
gouvernement et c'est donc pas une fin
de non-recevoir comme nous la infligé le
rapporteur sans argumentation valable
donc
nous allons retirer notre amendement en
attirant quand même toujours votre
attention madame la ministre sur
l'enseignement professionnel on le
retire parce qu'on sait qu'il sera pas
voté mais voilà les choses ont été dites
dans l'hémicycle et ça fait valoir notre
point de vue
ensuite nous avons des amendements en
discussion commune commençons par le 611
défendu par Madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement initialement travaillé avec
Ludes propose une hausse de crédit
permettant de maintenir le nombre de
parcours en poids compétences et la
durée totale de 24 mois des parcours en
compétence avec le renouveler en
ajoutant 150 millions d'euros au
programme Accès au retour à l'emploi
afin de soutenir l'insertion de l'emploi
et l'emploi réellement je dirais parce
que le gouvernement propose de diminuer
dans le PLF pour 2023 le nombre de pecs
passant de 80000 compte 100000 en 2022
donc c'est une réduction et je crois
qu'il faudrait quand même de l'ambition
réelle pour en faveur des jeunes
merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement
cet amendement est relatif à cette
diminution des parcours en poids
compétences pour rappeler quand même que
lorsqu'on a porté un coup au contrat
aidé en 2018 on a provoqué un vaste plan
social silencieux avec la suppression de
250 000 contrats et ce alors même que la
DARES en 2017 écrivait que les contrats
aidés permettent de soutenir
effectivement l'emploi voilà que le
gouvernement porte un nouveau coup de
rabot assez contrats parcours en point
compétences sans que cela nous semble
justifier d'aucune manière il faut
mettre fin vraiment au changement
intempestif concernant la prise en
charge notamment dans certaines régions
en Île-de-France par exemple en mars
dernier l'arrêté préfectorale limitait
les possibilités de renouvellement à 6
mois et le taux de prise en charge à 40%
à 45% un coup de canif énorme pour les
acteurs dans l'Ardèche la transformation
des contrats aidés en parcours de
compétences c'est c'est accompagner
d'une baisse de 72% du nombre de
contrats entre 2017 et 2018 en 2022 nous
sommes donc à 67000 bénéficiaires en
parcours en poids compétences au total
ce qui est peu contenu du nombre de
personnes éloignées de l'emploi dans le
pays et du nombre d'acteurs
collectivités ou associations qui
peuvent accueillir et qui peuvent aussi
bénéficier d'un appui via ce dispositif
il faut donc faire plus en conséquence
nous proposons d'allouer les 150
millions d'euros qui correspondent tout
simplement au maintien pour 2023 des
paramètres appliqués en 2022 concernant
ces contrats et donc à savoir 100 000
emplois pour une durée totale de 24 mois
renouvellement inclus et taux de prise
en charge compris
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
juste revenir sur la revanche qui m'a
été faite tout à l'heure par Madame
Cohen ça n'est pas du tout
un manque de respect vis-à-vis de la
question qui était posée du fait que
j'ai renvoyé au ministre mais en fait il
se trouve que je suis rapporteur spécial
du budget de travail emploi et les
crédits dont vous sollicitiez
l'augmentation sont des crédits de la
mission enseignement supérieur auquel je
ne connais rien donc je préférerais que
ça soit madame la ministre qui réponde
et qui vous apporte la réponse complète
et ceux de plus en plus que nous sommes
dans un temps contraint donc n'y voyez
pas une forme de désinvolture de ma part
ou de désintérêt c'est juste que je
souhaitais que vous ayez une réponse
complète et charpenter que je ne n'étais
pas en mesure de vous apporter pour ces
deux amendements c'est un avis
défavorable pour la raison suivante les
budgets le budget
de cette année prévoit un maintien des
entrées en contrat aidé dans le secteur
non marchand donc les fameux pecs au
même niveau que 2022 avec une diminution
portant sur les contrats dans le secteur
non marchands qui ne sont pas visés par
votre amendement la relance des contrats
aidé est intervenue dans le contexte
exceptionnel de la crise sanitaire la
situation aujourd'hui objectivement
n'est plus la même et traditionnellement
la commission des finances est assez
réservée sur ce type de dispositif donc
la vie est défavorable sur ces deux
amendements qui visent à augmenter de
150 millions d'euros la dotation pour
les contrats aidés
je voudrais souligner chers collègues
que il va rester il reste 22 amendements
et il reste 50 minutes
donc il est clair que si tout le monde
utilise pleinement son droit à la parole
la fin de la mission bascule sur la fin
de semaine il faut le savoir
pour ça
on ne parlera plus beaucoup après
monsieur le Président
puisque de toute façon c'est comme vous
l'avez dit contraint par des horaires
voilà sur les contrats aidés sur les
contrats pecs excusez-moi sur la
proposition qui est faite par nos
collègues nous allons soutenir même si
dans mon groupe nous pensons que les
contrats ne sont pas la panacée parce
que ce qui peut régler le problème
aujourd'hui et bien des gens les plus
éloignés de l'emploi ce sont
de véritables formations et de
véritables emploi et non pas des petits
contrats qui finalement s'arrêtent à
jour ou l'autre ceci dit ça a été dit on
a supprimé les contrats aidés
aujourd'hui les budgets alloués par
l'État à Pôle emploi ont été suspendus
notamment les contrats pour les
municipalités nous avons été interpellés
par de nombreux maires qui du jour au
lendemain ont été avertis que leurs
contrats pecs étaient interrompu et pour
les petites communes il faut bien se le
dire c'est un coup supplémentaire ceci
dit
je pense que c'est contrats avaient un
intérêt lorsque ces gens se retrouvaient
dans les municipalités c'est qu'il
pouvait bénéficier d'une formation et
d'un retour
et d'un retour peu à peu à l'emploi
puisqu'on leur permettait de se remettre
le pied à l'étrier et donc pour ces
raisons même si nous pensons que la
formation est essentielle nous allons
soutenir les amendements de nos
collègues
je me vois donc pour commencer
l'amendement 600 vous avez une double
avis défavorable qui est pour
contre
sont le plus exclus je vous remercie
monsieur le Président alors c'est le
premier amendement d'une série assez
importante d'amendements qui vise à
majorer les crédits destinés aux
structures d'insection d'insertion par
l'activité économique
l'activité enfin l'insertion par
l'activité économique et
incontestablement une forme extrêmement
pertinente d'accompagnement vers
l'emploi notamment pour les demandeurs
d'emploi de très longue durée des
bénéficiaires du RSA ou des jeunes très
éloignés de l'emploi
les crédits sont en légère progression
en 2023 et les structures d'IAE aurait
sans doute souhaité disposer d'une marge
budgétaire plus importante d'où cette
série d'amendements toutefois le secteur
je vous le rappelle a été extrêmement
soutenu ces quatre dernières années les
crédits étaient 840 millions en 2018 et
de 900 millions en 2019 ils sont passés
à 1,3 milliards en 2023 c'est une
augmentation de l'ordre de 50% sur les
quatre dernières années
compte tenu de cette progression sur
trois ans du niveau de consommation de
crédit en 2022 qui est d'environ 1,2
milliards de la légère augmentation
cette année et par ailleurs de l'effort
budgétaire dont nous parlons beaucoup
depuis le début de cette matinée
il me semble qu'il n'est pas
souhaitable d'aller au-delà de la
datation prévue pour 2023 donc c'est
donc un avis de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
[Musique]
avec deux amis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre
attention il n'est pas adopté 614
madame jasmin
merci monsieur
le Président c'est amendement vise à
créer un programme spécifique pour la
santé mentale et particulièrement la
santé mentale du travail ailleurs la
France se caractérise par un déficit de
reconnaissance des maladies psychiques
au travail comme maladie professionnelle
alors que la loi numéro
2015-994 du 17 août 2015 relative au
dialogue social et à l'emploi dites-loi
Rebsamen dispose bien que les maladies
psychiques peuvent être reconnues comme
maladie d'origine professionnelle le
coût économique de ces maladies entre
1,9 à 3 milliards d'euros par an est
élevé et nous constatons qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'effets par ce gouvernement
pour cette prise en compte donc nous
voulons créer ce programme avec des
fonds diesel et dédiés à la santé
mentale du travailleur un fond de 100
millions d'euros avec une autorisation
d'engagement de crédit de paiement je
souhaite vraiment que vous puissiez
prendre en compte cette situation merci
alors c'est un amendement donc vous
l'avez compris qui vise à créer un
nouveau programme avec un fond dédié à
la santé mentale doté de 100 millions
d'euros
donc c'est un rendement est assez
compliqué parce que
c'est compliqué de faire le rapport
entre le constat qui est fait entre
cette difficulté que nous avons à
reconnaître davantage les maladies
mentales dans l'entreprise avec le fait
que l'amendement lui-même constate qu'il
y a de plus en plus de reconnaissance en
maladie professionnelle des des maladies
des syndromes notamment au fond
dépressifs
cependant je vois pas bien en quoi la
création d'un fonds de 100 millions
d'euros pourraient améliorer notamment
ce qu'indique le l'amendement les
sanctions à l'égard de ce type de
comportement donc j'entends le sujet
j'entends la politique qui peut être
menée pour renforcer la lutte contre les
maladies professionnelles et notamment
les maladies mentales mais quel type
d'action financerait ces 100 millions
demandés il me semble que l'exposé des
motifs reste extrêmement floue sur la
question et c'est donc un avis
défavorable puis du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice nous partageons l'enjeu autour
de la prise en charge de la santé
mentale et d'une meilleure prévention et
pour cela le gouvernement est pleinement
engagé pleinement engagé déjà par
l'engagement pris et le travail effectué
par l'Agence nationale pour
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
qui ont publié des guides pour
effectivement accompagner cet enjeu mais
je voudrais rappeler également et vous
le savez
pour cause le la loi du 2 août 2021 qui
vient améliorer la prévention en santé
au travail et qui a largement accompagné
ce sujet là notamment entre autour du
rendez-vous de liaison des services de
prévention santé au travail de la lutte
contre la désinsertion professionnelle
et d'un certain nombre d'outils qui
viennent accompagner notamment cet enjeu
de la santé mentale et ça a fait l'objet
lors des discussions parlementaires d'un
attachement fort de l'ensemble des
parlementaires des deux chambres pour
que cet enjeu là soit bien pris en
compte dans les
pour le renforcement de la prévention en
santé au travail puis je voudrais
rappeler aussi le travail des comités
régionaux de reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles qui a été renforcée et
terminé aussi par le vous rappeler le
quatrième plan santé au travail qui
depuis décembre 2021 à là aussi
renforcer un certain nombre d'axes
notamment celui des tpeme qui ont été
mieux outillés pour qui développe des
outils pour travailler sur les risques
psychosociaux qui a également prévu de
faire une meilleure prévention pour le
secteur agricole dont on sait que les
enjeux en santé au travail sont
extrêmement importants à également prévu
de mieux spécialiser des consultants
pour accompagner cet enjeu là et à
souhaiter développer aussi
l'accompagnement lors de l'évolution
organisationnelles des entreprises pour
accompagner l'enjeu de la santé au
travail avec une dotation exceptionnelle
de 2,1 million d'euros je tiendrai
rappeler donc je crois que cet enjeu là
est d'ores et déjà très accompagné très
suivi et c'est un axe évidemment que
nous partageons avec vous dans
l'importance que vous souhaitez lui
donner
14 je parle des pour l'amendement 614
avec double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre
abstention et pas adoptée
654 tombe ensuite nous avons quatre
amendements de discussions communes en
commençant par le 717 madame poursu
Pauline
merci monsieur le Président notre
amendement est donc un amendement
d'appel qui vise à renforcer les crédits
de l'inclusion par l'activité économique
de 100 millions d'euros afin d'augmenter
le nombre de postes consacrés à ce
secteur en 2023 si le gouvernement veut
atteindre le plein emploi il faut mettre
les moyens à la hauteur de ses ambitions
en s'adressant à celles et ceux qui sont
le plus éloigné du marché du travail le
secteur de l'insertion par l'activité
des entreprises
représentaient est un secteur en
dynamique porté par les entreprises
d'insertion les entreprises de travail
temporaire d'insertion et les
entreprises d'insertion par le travail
indépendant notre amendement vise donc à
envoyer un signal de soutien à ce
secteur je vous remercie
oui merci monsieur le Président je vais
défendre l'amendement de mon collègue
mouillé qui n'a pas pu être présent
alors il pèse un peu moins que celui de
discussion
on fait la présentation et on peut se
séparer donc je reprends
donc du coup c'est un amendement qui
pèse un peu moins que celui de notre
collègue puisqu'il pèse effectivement 30
millions d'euros c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre que je crois qu'on est tous
attaché à la aux structures d'insertion
par l'activité économique et que les
gouvernements précédents ont fait un
effort considérable sur les SIAE on a eu
un texte de loi il y a pas très
longtemps en cette hémicycle je crois
que personne ne doute de nos intérêts
sur sur ces outils là par contre quand
on regarde quand même les chiffres avec
précision monsieur le ministre on
s'aperçoit quand même que même en
considérant la sous-consommation 2022
que vous avez évoquée mettre 1,27% de
plus au global ne rattrape pas la hausse
unitaire de 9,5% à partir de là les
structures ont deux solutions soit
effectivement elles arrêtent de faire
des contrats soit elle privilégie
elle-même à certains de contrats plutôt
sur ce qui est peu coûteux c'est
d'ailleurs les associations
intermédiaires et non pas les chantiers
d'insertion moi je considère nous ne
considérons que ce ne sont pas aux
structures de faire ses choix mais que
c'est un choix politique et donc deux
possibilités soit on fait un choix
politique et on dit on met plutôt
l'accent sur les associations
intermédiaires du coup on suit pas
forcément vous avez besoin du terrain
soit on fait une rallonge de l'ordre de
30 millions d'euros c'est ce que nous
vous proposons dans cet amendement
identique 488 de Monsieur Bruyer
ses collègues merci monsieur le
Président alors le gouvernement
effectivement nous annonce le retour au
plein d'emploi il nous semble
indispensable que cette amélioration
profite aussi à celles et ceux des plus
éloignés du marché du travail pour cela
donc nous proposons comme il a été dit
de soutenir l'insertion par l'activité
économique en prévoyant budgétairement
davantage en 2023 en effet si le budget
présenté pour 2023 est en augmentation
en valeur il est en réalité en
diminution en nombre
d'équivalent en plein finançable contenu
de la hausse du SMIC vous savez que la
loi prévoit en effet que les montants
unitaires des aides au poste sont
indexés sur le SMIC aussi cet amendement
permet de poursuivre la dynamique du
pacte d'ambition pour l'insertion par
l'activité économique et aussi je vous
propose de préserver cette dynamique de
l'effort budgétaire car c'est un
investissement
oui merci monsieur le Président
j'ajouterai juste quelques mots c'est
que si le budget effectivement on
augmentation en valeur puisqu'il parle
passe pardon de 1 milliard 299 à 1
milliards 300 16 bon en réalité il est
en diminution en raison du nombre de TP
finançable compte tenu de la hausse du
SMIC et donc par ailleurs la loi prévoit
que les montants unitaires des aides au
poste sont indexées sur le SMIC d'où la
nécessité de majorer de 30 millions
cette ligne
maintenant la vie de la commission d'une
part sur le 717 et ensuite sur les trois
amendements identiques
alors la vie de la commission je l'ai
déjà donné tout à l'heure sur l'ensemble
des amendements de ce type c'est un avis
défavorable sur les quatre avec
évidemment un regard plus spécifique sur
les trois amendements identiques
mouillés broyés et ferait qui sont
évidemment extrêmement
sympathique et généreux mais faut quand
même qu'on oublie pas et c'est le rôle
de la Commission des finances on a dit
tout à l'heure qu'il fallait faire
attention aux dépenses publiques qu'il
fallait réduire même le budget de la
mission travail emploi on peut pas de
l'autre côté répondre à une demande qui
est tout à fait
légitime de des acteurs de l'insertion
par l'activité économique il faut un
travail formidable mais qui ont vu leur
budget progresser de façon très très
sensible ces quatre dernières années ça
a été rappelé par le ministre tout à
l'heure plus 400 millions d'euros sur
les quatre dernières années le budget
augmente cette année également de peu
près 16 millions d'euros de mémoire ça
ne couvre sans doute pas effectivement
mais au titre de la commission des
finances je ne peux pas donner un avis
favorable
donc je mets
attention le compteur est toujours dans
le rouge
dans le corps rapporteur que je suis
tiens confirmé qu'Emmanuel qui a pu a
bien donné la vie de la commission il
tient aussi à on a parlé de santé
mentale à éviter le risque de
schizophrénie pour les rapporteurs le
rapporteur spécial que je suis qui a
signé un désamendement juste pour
souligner que cet amendement était très
débattu et il a donné le résultat de la
Commission
nous allons retirer notre amendement
pour donner plus de poids à ce de nos
collègues qui demandent un peu moins
mais bon voilà on va être raisonnable
alors je mets où voir les trois
amendements
identiques commençant par la société
avec deux avis des favorables qui pour
qui est contre
censions qui sont adopter
merci Monsieur la Président c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste a pour
objet la revalorisation salariale des
postes permanents dans les ateliers
d'insertion et les associations
intermédiaires pour un montant de 80
millions 817 310 euros il s'agit de
maintenir une qualité de
l'accompagnement mis en oeuvre dans ces
différentes structures merci
la vie de la commission sur le 608 c'est
le même avis précédemment c'est un
retrait où défavorable
défavorables qui est pour
abstention et pas adopté 613
également madame
oui et bien c'est amendement du groupe
socialiste vise à développer la
formation dans les IAE le budget de
formation pour l'insertion par
l'activité économique et porter à 100
millions d'euros en 2023 au sein du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences en
augmentation de plus de 25% par rapport
à
222 donc il s'agit maintenant de prendre
en compte les nouveaux besoins pour
permettre la réalisation de toutes les
formations dans ce cadre je vous
remercie
je me vois donc c'est un rendement aussi
ils sont très avec double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté 661 madame manger
pour moi
merci monsieur le Président alors
l'expérimentation territoire zéro
Schumer conduite entre 2016 et 2021 est
un dispositif dynamique qui a permis à
plus d'un millier de personnes éloignées
de l'emploi de retrouver du travail 50
nouveaux territoires peuvent désormais
l'être entre juillet 21 et juillet 2024
sachant que l'association pense être en
mesure de couvrir 60 territoires d'ici
2023 ainsi afin que cette
expérimentation qui rappelons-le permet
le retour à des emplois en CDI des
emplois à la forte utilité sociale et
environnementale donc répondant à
l'inspiration d'y trouver du sens et qui
participe aux dynamisme des territoires
puissent vraiment se déployer il faut
que les crédits alloués soient
suffisants dès lors par cet amendements
nous souhaitons augmenter les moyens
d'évolu aux expérimentations territoire
zéro chômeur de longue durée ont vu
notamment de l'augmentation du nombre de
territoires habilités afin qu'aucun
projet mature ne se voit refuser par
manque de crédit
merci
donc cette cette amendement visa majorit
50 millions d'euros les crédits pour
l'expérimentation en territoire zéro
chômeur de longue durée
ces crédits ont déjà
progressé notamment en 2023 puisqu'il
passe de 33 à 45 millions d'euros avec
l'amendement serait donc une
multiplication par 3 sur un an et je ne
suis pas certain même avec l'extension à
de nouveaux territoires volontaires
qu'une telle montée en charge soit
réaliste compte tenu du niveau constaté
des embourgeons les entreprises à but
d'emploi depuis le début de
l'expérimentation dont tout le monde se
satisfait sur le terrain mais le
l'enjeu pareil un petit peu fort pour
cette année
demande de retrait ou un avis
défavorable
qui est pour
contre
il est pas adopté
607 madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste a pour
objectif l'augmentation de fonds de
développement de l'inclusion pour un
montant total de 20 millions d'euros
alors il serait temps également que nous
puissions être dans un dispositif de
cohérence également parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de chômage et quand on prend
des mesures pour essayer de trouver des
solutions y compris pour les structures
d'accompagnement de nos jeunes et bien
on voit que rien n'est adopté il a ça me
surprend considérablement merci
retrait ou défavorable je précise qu'on
a déjà augmenté de 30 millions d'euros
tout à l'heure donc là c'est 20 millions
mais complémentaire
avec deux amis des favorables qui sont
ceux qui sont pour retirer
ensuite deux amendements discussion
commune le premier de Madame Ferrat et
des collègues de son groupe monsieur
Hainaut oui merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
comme j'ai déjà développé
l'argumentation en faveur de cette
amendement dans mon dans mon
intervention de tout à l'heure je ne
développe pas mais il s'agit de proposer
une augmentation de 5 millions d'euros
pour le dispositif des maisons de
l'emploi qui a été créée par Jean-Louis
Borloo je vous remercie
oui c'est exactement le même c'est le
même amendement que celui de nos
collègues centrist donc effectivement
nous trouvons que c'est tout à fait
dommageable de mettre en danger un outil
qui est précieux sur les sur les
territoires et d'ailleurs un outil pour
lequel les mers sont particulièrement
attachés et c'est important d'avoir un
lien de proximité avec les personnes qui
sont éloignées de l'emploi et donc c'est
pourquoi nous nous faisons cet
amendement je vous remercie
la vie de la commission oui nous sommes
tous attachés aux maisons de l'emploi au
Sénat mais les amendements vise à
reconduire les financements de l'année
dernière et le rapporteur spécial à
l'Assemblée nationale a déjà introduit
par amendement cette hausse de 5
millions que vous sollicitez donc en
réalité cette amendement est satisfait
c'est la raison pour laquelle
personnellement je ne l'ai pas déposé
cette année comme je le déposais
d'habitude chaque année comme vous mes
chers collègues donc il est satisfait
c'est donc une demande de retraite
c'est le même avis pour une raison qui
m'échappe un peu monsieur le Président
le financement des maisons de l'emploi
est systématiquement pourvu par
amendement parlementaire et rarement
dans la maquette initiale du PLF nous
avons reconduit cette tradition mais
comme l'a dit le rapporteur à l'instant
l'amendement du rapporteur spécial de
l'Assemblée nationale tel qu'il a été
intégré à l'occasion de l'engagement du
49-3 permet de satisfaire les deux
amendements qui sont déposés donc c'est
une demande de retrait
retirer
qui est pour
qui est contre
abstention
et pas adopté
par le 616 madame Vogel merci monsieur
le Président cet amendement propose
d'évaluer les coûts et les modalités
d'adaptation du monde du travail à la
crise climatique nous ne savons tout et
tous le réchauffement climatique est
déjà là et si nous continuons sur la
même trajectoire il fera en moyenne 3,2
degrés de plus d'ici la fin du siècle et
quand bien même nous prendrions dès
aujourd'hui les décisions nécessaires
pour éviter la catastrophe certains
impacts de la crise climatique sont
irréversibles et face à ces derniers il
y a pas le choix il faut nous adapter
dès maintenant et notamment adapter le
monde du travail avec une simple hausse
des températures mondiales de 1,5° qui
elle malheureusement est inéluctable
plus de 20 millions de travailleurs
seraient exposés chaque année à un
risque de décès en raison d'une chaleur
excessive 2,2% des heures de travail
annuel pourraient être perdu
mondialement le boom de l'utilisation de
la climatisation que nous avons vu cet
été et plus qu'une impasse c'est un
accélérateur de la crise c'est donc vers
d'autres changements qu'il faut aller
sur de travail sur les rythmes sur
l'année sur les tâches les lieux de
travail leur adaptabilité au vague de
chaleur
pour cette raison une des propositions
du rapport sénatorial dont j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être la rapportrice sur la
sécurité sociale écologique était
dévaluer la prévalence des pics de
chaleur dans les années à venir afin
d'encourager les employeurs et
employeurs à s'y préparer afin de
préserver la santé des travailleurs et
des travailleurs cet amendement ne fait
que refléter cette proposition et
propose donc des fonds pour une étude
dédiée à l'évaluation des coûts et des
modalités d'adaptation du monde du
travail de demain à la réalité du
réchauffement climatique et évidemment
nous demandons au gouvernement de lever
le gage
justifier le projet annuel de
performance de la mission travail et
emploi prévoit que l'année 23 sera je
cite malgré marqué par plusieurs
chantiers d'importance sur la stratégie
globale de l'établissement public et la
politique de certification
professionnelle que l'agence conduit
pour le ministère du travail ce qui a
été décidé je cite encore de lui
transférer plusieurs missions sur la
politique du titre professionnel du
ministère du Travail aujourd'hui assuré
par les services déconcentrés pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons il convient
donc de maintenir le plafond d'emploi à
son niveau de 2022 tel est le sens de
l'amendement
et enfin dans la discussion comme j'ai
vous avez deux autres amendements 619 et
merci monsieur le Président alors le 619
très à l'étude sur un congé parental
égal en France l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes dans l'ensemble des
espaces de la société est très loin
d'atatinte et en particulier au niveau
des salaires et de la charge parentale
un des événements majeurs qui structure
cette inégalité c'est l'arrivée d'un
premier enfant dans un couple
hétérosexuel la charge de la parentalité
revient majoritairement à la mer
affectant durablement sa carrière et
conditionnant un rôle social au sein de
la famille et plus largement sa société
l'existence de cette inégalité elle est
favorisée encouragée construite par
notre société qui attribue à la mer qui
a couché principalement et de façon
totalement disproportionnée par rapport
au père ou au deuxième parent la charge
de s'en occuper après la naissance via
un congé parentalité absolument
inégalitaire
en effet bien que le congé paternité
était un peu allongé il demeure plus
court que le congé maternité sans aucune
justification et de nombreux pairs ont
des difficultés pour l'obtenir auprès de
leur employeur et employeuse conséquence
si son salaire était déjà en faire
inférieur à celui de son conjoint ou
s'il était à peu près similaire les
études démontrent que ce n'est plus le
cas ensuite pour la mer par ailleurs
l'inégalité entre les deux parents
vis-à-vis du congé parentalité créer une
fort discrimination à l'embauche puisque
les employeurs savent qu'une femme en
âge de procréer pourrait partir en congé
maternité et que ce risque est presque
nul en cas d'embauche d'un homme en âge
de procréer il n'y a pourtant aucune
raison qui puisse justifier si l'on
reconnaît qu'un enfant à deux parents de
ne pas reconnaître le même congé pour
les deux parents la seule manière
d'assurer l'égalité c'est d'avoir un
congé parentalité égal et obligatoire il
existe plusieurs modèles dans le monde
comme en Suède ou en Espagne et je vous
propose simplement d'étudier simplement
d'étudier comment nous pourrions
instaurer un congé parental obligatoire
de 16 semaines pour aller vers une
société plus égalitaire je vous remercie
vous avez défendu les deux madame
l'autre n'a rien à voir
donc le 621 maintenant c'est un
amendement qui vise à étudier la mise en
place d'un congé menstruel alors je vous
apprends rien quand je vous dis que la
moitié de la population française
environ a eu ou aura ses règles pendant
environ 38 ans de sa vie cette réalité
objective de la vie de la moitié de la
population trois jours par mois pendant
à peu près la moitié de sa vie est
entouré d'un tabou on ne dit pas qu'on a
ses règles on se passe des tampons
discrètement comme c'était une honte et
on ne traite pas socialement le fait que
les règles impactent nos vies peuvent
engendrer des douleurs des effets
objectivement handicapants pendant
quelques jours pour travailler certaines
femmes et personnes menstrues ont le
sentiment qu'on leur enfonce des clous
dans le ventre qu'on leur coupe les
organes ont des bouffées de chaleur maux
de tête des vertiges etc alors parfois
il s'agit des effets secondaires de
l'endométriose oui puis parfois pas
personnellement j'ai parfois tellement
mal que je peux pas me lever mais j'ai
pas d'endométriose or la société ne
prévoit pas de gérer cette réalité le
monde du travail a été fabriqué par des
hommes pour des hommes et des femmes
s'emploie à ne pas faire exister une
spécificité de peur d'être discriminés
alors beaucoup d'adaptations sont à
faire pour prendre en compte le fait que
les menstruations existent l'une d'entre
elles qui doivent venir dans un ensemble
de mesures c'est le congé menstruel je
vous propose donc ne réfléchir à sa
création en Espagne il est possible de
prendre trois jours de congés 5 en cas
de symptômes aiguës en France plusieurs
entreprises ont choisi d'expérimenter
avec succès ce dispositif ce qui va dans
le bon sens mais il faudrait qu'il soit
étendu afin de couvrir toutes les
personnes concernées d'autant que je
vous le rappelle 68% des françaises sont
en faveur d'un congé menstruel
alors sur ces quatre amendements mais
sur rapporteur la ville de la commission
oui monsieur le Président très
rapidement sur ces quatre amendements
qui sont en discussion commune mais qui
n'ont en commun que le gage puisque vous
avez compris qu'on touche à quatre
sujets extrêmement variés dans l'ordre
donc le changement climatique pour les
cartes c'est un avis c'est une demande
de retraite ou sinon un avis des
favorable
sur la transition écologique ça fait
partie très clairement des axes de
travail de l'anacte donc de l'agence
nationale d'amélioration des conditions
de travail donc il ne nous semble pas
opportun de créer un fond spécial
d'adaptation qui serait crédité de 5
millions d'euros pour l'AFPA c'est
également un avis de retrait ou
défavorable puisque l'AFPA est fortement
soutenu par l'État et à bénéficier d'une
subvention complémentaire en PLFR et
elle doit continuer à se restructurer
sur les deux derniers amendements ou
notre Collex les a même intervertis
puisque c'était d'abord le congé l'étude
sur le congé menstruel qui est bien le
619 et 621 portes sur le congé parental
égalitaire
on comprend bien l'idée ce sont des
sujets qui dépassent largement les
compétences de la mission travail emploi
et qui font plus l'objet de débats
sociaux je dirais qui sont tout à fait
importants il me semble pas que l'étude
d'une nouvelle évolution législative
puisque c'est une nouvelle étude
législation qui est appelée de vos vœux
rentre dans les
demandes des crédits supplémentaires ça
rentre dans les dans les fonctions et
dans les crédits inhérents au ministère
du Travail à la Délégation Générale
au travail la direction pardon de telle
sorte que je vous en demande le retrait
donc je vais mettre voix successivement
c'est quatre amendements avec un avis de
retrait ou défavorable de la commission
et la vie des favorable du Gouvernement
nous commençons par l'amendement 616 qui
est pour
qui est contre
l'abstention et pas adopté amendement
716 également avis défavorable et le
gouvernement même vote
nous allons procéder au vote des crédits
de la mission donc travaillant
n'est pas une demande d'explication de
vote je rappelle que la ville de la
commission est favorable commission des
finances et favorable à l'adoption des
crédits de la mission je le mets au vois
mais j'ai une demande de scrutin public
du groupe les républicains sur la
mission avec un ami favorable de
gouverte de la de la commission il va
être procédé au secrétaire public dans
les commissions dans les conditions du
règlement
il nous en restera trois après
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà le résultat votant 343 exprimé 331
pour les crédits 240 contre 91 donc les
crédits sont adoptés nous avons encore à
discuter les articles attachésion
article 47 je le mets au revoir qui est
pour
contre il est adopté article 48 je le
mets également aux voix qui est pour
contre
abstention il est adopté à l'article 49
j'ai trois amendements en discussion
comme une commence par Madame Lavarde
678 oui merci monsieur le Président
alors en fait c'est amendement suit
exactement la même logique que ceux qui
ont été déposés par les deux rapporteurs
sauf qu'il va plus loin puisque
l'amendement des rapporteurs prévoient
la possibilité de moduler le prix pour
certaines formations et donc moi mon
amendement prévoit en fait un
plafonnement pour toutes les formations
et introduit aussi un ticket modérateur
alors pourquoi parce que enfin moi je
pense que ce qui est gratuit n'a pas de
valeur donc si on veut vraiment engager
pleinement les gens dans un processus de
formation et que ce soit pas la réponse
à un coup de fil on leur dit vous avez
un compte n'oubliez pas d'utiliser vos
crédits bah si on les fait participer un
peu on est certain qui c'est un
gorgeront et qui seront vraiment acteurs
de cette formation et bien évidemment
l'idée n'est pas de faire payer ce
ticket modérateur tout le monde quand la
formation elle s'inscrit dans une
procédure de retour à l'emploi dans une
procédure de réorientation
professionnelle là il n'y a pas lieu
d'être parce qu'on est vraiment dans un
accompagnement vers le marché du travail
mais par contre pour toutes les autres
formations qui parfois peuvent être des
formations pas de confort mais peut-être
un peu moins engagé il me semble qu'il
est vraiment
utile d'introduire ce plafonnement et ce
ticket modérateur ensuite monsieur le
rapporteur
puis ça vous présenter vos amendements
alors merci monsieur le Président donc
on a un amendement de la commission des
finances qui a été travaillé avec la
commission des affaires sociales qui
vise le même objectif de régulation mais
qui est plus
raisonnable et plus limité
de façon moins budgétaire je vous
rappelle que l'augmentation forte et non
maîtrisée des dépenses induites par du
CPF justifie la mise en place de
mécanismes de régulation c'est ce qui
est prévu par l'article 49 du
gouvernement nous souhaitons juste
augmenter
ce mécanisme de régulation en prévoyant
qu'un plafonnement soit possible nous
n'allons pas jusqu'à faire ce que
sollicite madame l'avarede comme ça je
défends je donne mon avis en même temps
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je lui
demanderai de retirer le sien au profit
de l'amendement de la commission des
finances et de la commission des
affaires sociales parce que l'objectif
n'est pas de mettre un ticket modérateur
obligatoire ce qui ressortirait de
l'amendement de Madame lavard de la
façon dont il est rédigé
la mission que nous avions conduite avec
Martin lévrier et corinne-ferret qui
consistait effectivement à ce qu'on est
un reste à charge pour les personnes qui
faisaient des formations avec un
objectif de recentrer le CPF sur
l'employabilité d'utilisateurs et sur le
développement des compétences à finalité
professionnelle en ce sens on rejoint
tout à fait les objectifs de Christine
Avard qui je le comprends à une vision
budgétaire de ce qui se passe sur France
compétences parce que je pense que les
PLFR à 2 milliards qui nous arrivent
régulièrement comment ça a vraiment nous
poser question sur notre capacité à
équilibrer France compétences donc bien
entendu que je défends l'amendement que
nous avons posé mais je comprends tout à
fait la position de Christine Lavarde
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs effectivement
même avis que la Commission au fond le
l'enjeu effectivement et d'accompagner
le compte personnel de formation
maintenant dans un degré de maturité si
le CPF est un vrai succès avec 5,5
millions d'ouverture de ces contes de
formation qui ouvrent l'accès aux droits
à formation et à la mobilisation de ses
droits à formation cette un vrai succès
c'est un vrai succès populaire que nous
souhaitons bien sûr accompagner
néanmoins nous avons évidemment le
partage avec vous de cette profonde
conviction et de cette nécessité d'avoir
un mécanisme de régulation pour que ces
fonds soient mobilisés à des fins
d'employabilité et de maintien dans
l'emploi d'accompagnement des
compétences sur des projets
professionnels et donc c'est là je
reviens l'objet du de la proposition
d'amendement pour le ticket modérateur
la proposition que que vous faites
effectivement du coup généralise cette
cette modalité est donc nous nous aurons
un avis défavorable je voudrais dire
aussi que le dialogue social est en
cours de discussion sur ces modalités
d'usage du CPF et que nous accompagnons
bien sûr le dialogue social pour que
effectivement il puisse avoir un avis
sur cette orientation sur un projet
professionnel solide donc un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
sur les deux autres
28 et 376 sagesse
madame l'avare je vous avais une demande
de retrait qu'en pensez-vous ah non mais
j'ai peut-être une lecture trop
budgétaire mais moi je vais laisser mon
amendement juste quand même pour
Monsieur Capu c'est les modalités des
deux dispositifs sont définies par
décret donc ça ne veut pas dire que ce
sera obligatoire pour tout le monde et
j'entends la ministre dire qu'elle est
prête à faire des reformes mais surtout
n'allons pas trop vite enfin je veux
dire à chaque fois qu'on fait un texte
budgétaire on rajoute en gros 2
milliards sur France compétences alors
je veux bien que les milliards pleuvent
mais il faut vraiment engager ce sujet
et là ce que je vous propose c'est de le
faire et ensuite par décret bien
évidemment de choisir les cas de figure
ou le plat ou le ticket modérateur n'a
pas raison de s'appliquer mais pour tous
les autres enfin sinon on va continuer à
être harcelé au téléphone et puis le
jour on a de l'argent on dira oui j'y
vais et puis quand on en a passé ben on
dira malheureusement je peux pas aller
faire cette formation mais peut-être
demain dès que j'aurai acquis à cette
droite donc là voilà c'est juste pour
essayer vraiment de rentrer dans ce
sujet
monsieur le ministre
simplement monsieur le Président pour
dire madame la sénatrice Labarthe que la
proposition de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale que vous allez
examiner interdire à purement et
simplement le démarchage téléphonique ce
qui est une bonne chose et traitera le
sujet par d'autres aspects je crains
qu'avec la rédaction qui soit qui la
vôtre le décret ne puisse plus permettre
justement une exonération totale de
ticket modérateur ce qui serait
problématique par exemple pour des
demandeurs d'emploi très longue durée
qui confrontaient à des difficultés
financières ne pourraient plus accéder à
la formation et donc il y a vraiment on
a vraiment une difficulté avec la
rédaction qui est la vôtre raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement préfère d'où la
vie de sagesse de exprimée permaname la
ministre les amendements 28 et 376
alors je mets au volant 678 de Madame
Labarde avec avis de retrait ou
défavorable des deux de la Commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
biens n'est pas adopté amendement 28 et
6 et 376 pardon
et maintenant des deux commissions avec
une sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
abstention ils sont adoptés
je mets donc on voit avec ses
amendements l'article 49 modifier qui
est pour l'article
contre
sanctions
à examiner sur la solidarité insertion
égalité des chances et dans la mesure où
l'organisation de la journée demain le
permet en accord avec la commission des
finances nous pourrions porter
exceptionnellement la durée maximale
prévisionnelle sur cette mission de 2h30
à 3h30 y a-t-il les oppositions
il y en a pas il en est ainsi décidé je
vais suspendre et la séance sera reprise
à 14h15 pour la mission ancien
combattant mémoire et lien avec la
nation la séance est suspendue
[Musique]